too hello hello everybody it is
Wednesday April 19th
one day before the infamous
uh 420 also known as our deer deer
I don't even know if I can say this name
this early in the show
he was uh celebrated by uh many
and and also hated by men
one of the prominent leap world leaders
of uh
Germany during World War II
we celebrate his birthday on 4 20 don't
we
that appears to be the case yeah so it's
it's so everybody has a cause to
celebrate
[Laughter]
Stoners and Libs who like smoking and
then and then obviously every
conservative will be celebrating 420 as
Hitler's birthday falls on that day
so well let's all just bury the hatchet
come together
yeah
here we go it's on 420 yet I smoke the
weed with my brothers even though Degas
was because I spoke the weed with my
brothers
even though they got gas Chambers it's 4
20.
it's faux
it's 4 20.
no it's 4 20.
just a reminder we're going no button
today yeah we have no button we're about
uh let's see a minute and 30 seconds in
and we are yes regretting that already
some say it's inappropriate
but I say it's the smoking and roll it
up and smoke it peace
it is an interesting the day to share
with Nazis
mm-hmm
he's like Jesus we celebrate his
birthday who else do you celebrate their
birthday like
except Jesus
you know the Easter Bunny
is this Easter Bunny's birthday Easter
um
what else they think he's Jesus
except I'll tell you what I'm okay Dave
it's his birthday right
it's his birthday okay so I'm okay
that's good
I'll tell you what though
I'll tell you what Hitler doesn't have
that Jesus does he's risen
he's up yep that [__] that [__] Hitler
is dead oh he down he down bad yeah we
got no button today we're fully off the
rails also guys experimenting with some
more on the nose type of branding for
off the rails as you guys can see
there is a tragic train wreck off the
rails uh and here is a plume of vinyl
chloride
filling the going to the clouds which
will bring it to the Metropolis
oh people are in chat remind me today's
bicycle day do you guys know what that
is oh we should oh we should have more
cause to celebrate guess who's tripping
instead I guess who's High wait bicycle
day it's the day uh the first LSD trip
happened why do they call it bicycle day
because the guy who made it was on a
bicycle ride I love too scientist who
made it he accidentally dosed himself
with like a hero dose of LSD the first
person to ever take LSD because he had
just synthesized it and then he went on
a bike ride all afternoon had the time
of his life so wow yeah is that what I
love my bicycle is about by Queen I like
to ride my bicycle I like to trip balls
where I go
uh a gas chamber is just code for hot
boxing cars thank you Lily K someone who
understands me
yo let's get in this gas chamber
420 bro let's HotBox this [__] gas
chamber right now
here's a good collab
bringing people together
yo dude let's get in the gas Shimmer but
instead of deadly fumes it's it's weed
Vapors bro you just get high yeah dude
hell yeah that's a hybrid that's a dope
hybrid celebration right there yeah
yo except for people clawing for their
lives and screaming and
okay that's enough did we just get we
just got a leg is it too dark too dark
too dark
um
I see people already complaining about
the lack of bunny in this new background
um which is interesting we could have a
rabbit maybe running by yeah desert
hairs or a thing right desert hairs are
a thing the bunny was actually on the
train favorite bunny no no a bee off the
rails baby
uh drink or food for a B on me
MFM art says my wife and I were lucky
enough to be in the VIP of the Clash and
we got to meet Amy at the opening party
he was nice enough to say hello we
didn't want to be weird with photos and
small talk you were super nice and you
put up a great fight you said hello to
them maybe oh thank you I was so
gracious of you I said hi to as many
people as I can
and it meant the world so thank you you
know what also got to give a shout out
to friend not just friends of the show
Almost the uncle of the show Steve
jablonski yeah legendary composer
he sent you a thousand bucks yep he said
congrats on amazing performance I know
Nathan he's an animal and also the
sweetest guy you guys put on a great
show I said something for you and Lena
that's so nice Legend good job he's wild
like that yeah
he's so generous he must be stacked
though
because that guy that guy's like super
generous very very successful composer
done a ton of huge stuff yeah he's
stacked I love that people like that
watch the show man I just that's like
great I love my ketamine therapy it
helps my depression well okay well it's
not ketamine day Buzz tree we'll save
that for MLK day or something
you know what I mean you say because MLK
MLK
and then MLK
uh ketamine is one of the drugs I have
not tried actually have any of you guys
tried ketamine I've done what's it like
did you take a big ass dose no no uh I I
did I did it like three times years ago
um what is it like I mean
is genuinely not like anything else I'll
say that does it last a while
um ish like is it euphoric
uh it's euphoric kind of like implies
more of an up it's more
like you go into a like hyper Serene
State I like that that sounds good yeah
hyper Serene that's that's probably the
best way I could describe so it's nice
it's a nice feeling it's very nice okay
okay wow that's amazing by the way we're
not recommending anybody take that for
the record I am only asking Dan about
his this is not with a medical
professional if you do because that's
right I mean right you can actually do
that in California or Los Angeles or
these
hey uh doctor I was thinking about
tripping some ketamine today are you
available
I'm a doctor I'm a [__]
[__] yeah so um
got a great show here today for you guys
um
the Zach lore video is out
that we've been hyping up for a long
time now oh yeah
I dropped it finally yesterday here it
is
uh it's two hours long it's an absolute
Behemoth we want it to be comprehensive
and it is comprehensive
and um I'm gonna like it because
if you don't me then who yep that's
right if not now then when I'm very
honored thank you
uh we have a little intro in the top and
like even just this this your classic
soundboard moments is [__] iconic
dude like that part alone just had me
dying
I do think this is one of the funniest
moments in the show's history she's so
[__] beautiful that [__] was not that
that was very funny you can't do that
I'm blocking because it's so insane that
you're hitting those sound bites but you
can't do that it's amazing artist named
this one yeah
Jesus that I mean I'm sorry Trisha but
that is sad what the [__] is wrong with
you
one of the [__] it's got to be top so
inappropriate that's top three I see a
lot of comments are saying about that
game maybe one I mean I don't know
we should make a funniest moments uh
like genuine like all-time funniest
moments I wonder how we would even
source that but if we could like uh
Source Discord and fans who are really
familiar with the show that would be a
fantastic video sure
top top 10 all-time great history
moments or something yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
anyway go uh watch it after this show
don't watch it now I mean we're live why
would you do that
but uh go watch it uh g g list g g silly
thank you for the 10 gifted
oh can I give a little update to the
members about yesterday's stream sure
where it's almost back up oh it is
um it got three block claims uh the
reasons no I block it yeah so I block it
three people blocked the stream and the
really fun part about that is YouTube
only lets you can trim the section
that's in violation out and they'll
remove the block however it only lets
you do them one at a time and every time
you do it the video has to process which
takes delete
an indeterminate amount of time
sometimes it goes relatively quickly
sometimes it takes like 12 hours so the
third one is processing now that's
faster than I expected yeah I I did two
last night and then I did the third one
this morning and uh so it should be back
up probably by the time Today's show is
over so if you were looking for that
that's what's going on yeah you know you
were asking what it was yeah beetles got
us
uh I forgot what the other two were but
I it's all music it's still listening to
the music thing yeah
it's probably not worth it just because
it's a headache nobody could watch it
except live right but yeah so that's
what's going on and I have actually a SK
a segment idea I want to throw to the
men uh sorry to exclude you ladies
although when you hear the idea I'm sure
you'll be happy to be excluded from this
one
um
as you know we're all
uh aging unfortunately yeah I myself at
37 years old the most senior in this
office although not by a lot Dan you're
35 right and they say
you know prostate cancer
um
rectal cancer these are all top top
killers of men young men too in their
Prime I mean wasn't the Black Panther
guy he he died of prostate cancer or
something wasn't it let me check
I mean my God total biscuit died of
prostate cancer I mean it's just tragic
[Music]
you just play ass it's the word ass
right there he did yes I did uh I asked
chat gbt men should consider getting
checked for prostate cancer
um he starts by saying I'm not a doctor
I know that you're a [__]
yeah so
colon cancer I think they checked for
that too you know I mean
this says that yeah by the way this says
chati BT says African-American men are
at higher risk or prostate cancer why is
that do you think I don't know it just
says obesity Maybe
just like the higher rates of obesity
what you call black people fat I thought
you said American men no I said black
and I said African Americans I just
heard the Americans
yeah like is it because they're all fat
no I was like what though I heard
America I mean that would be included in
America as well but yeah I thought you
said America African-American men are
interestingly
at higher risk for prostate cancer
uh but they say you know at 40 I think
is a is a good safe age to start
checking
how do you check
But but so in an effort of showing that
I'm Alpha that I support men Beyond and
above everybody else the chat's backing
me up by the way you said American men
not African Americans oh okay I'm sorry
I thought he said Africa I heard what
you said oh so we did so yeah I'm just
going off the chats feedback here okay
love is part of the chat no love boy
he'll always have your producer
yes so um
again you know a lot of people are
trying to claim that they care about men
Jordan Peterson Andrew Taylor all these
dumb ass red pill losers I care about
men
I want men to be healthy and so I have
volunteered myself
to the cause of men everywhere lead by
example that's that's what Alpha does
and on Wednesday at 37 years old
I will be performing my first prostate
exam
live on this show we're doing impossible
things and Performing reforming it huh
this is this is about to be performing
art it is a performance
and so this is this is my way
of of asserting my Alchemist without
shame without without fear
and to normalize this uh Act of being
sodomized by a doctor's finger
does that kind of saw to me probably not
no I don't think so hunger
now here's how I'm gonna do it I'm gonna
set up a curtain we already have a
Doctor by the way who's coming we got
him we're gonna set up a black curtain
so all you'll see
is the front part of my body and the
doctor will be back there isn't it gonna
be funny if it was just your face
sticking out like just your face sure
whatever they can't see yeah right the
point is they can't see the doctor isn't
Dr James weiner by any chance it's
actually Dr Drew Doctor Drew yeah and so
what I would like I don't want to be the
only one
I want to extend the invitation to all
you guys to show that men come first
that
um
that we stand United for men's health
and men's rights to be uh digitally
penetrated by a doctor I hope you get
asked cancer oh
interesting use of
yo chill Dr Phil
I'm trying to do a good thing Katie says
my dad got prostate cancer was very
scary for a whole family Lucky's in
remission there it is please get checked
so this is what I'm doing Katie all
right this is why I'm doing this and you
can send this to all the alphas and let
them know Ethan actually cares about men
when's the last time you performed a
prostate
well you won't be performing it it's a
performance receiving no but it is a
performance he'll be out come on when's
the last time anyone has actually
performed
there first ever yeah first so I want to
I want to I don't want to be I will I'm
willing to be the only one I'll tell you
right now I will do it by myself but as
we have a doctor here and it is a
necessary medical uh
uh thing
hold it I I would invite you all to
participate so who's in there who's in
with me I will be participating with my
general practitioner which I'll be
scheduling and and you will uh I will
have you he's a good doctor he's a good
doctor uh yeah so is mine so is mine
okay
so that's enough that was a no yeah not
not live on the show but I respect what
you're doing and what is your
reservation with it it just seems
awfully personal
well but you they've been a lot to do it
in front of you know a million people
especially for a first time maybe not
you know what maybe maybe for the second
time this is my second time I was oh I
got a finger in my butt when I was in
college
for or because they suspect I had a
hernia I don't know if that's how you
check that but
[Music]
it wasn't that bad I'll be I'll be
totally honest use lots of lube
like Vaseline or something
yeah I'm sure they do I'm sure they do
and so a b what about you
it's a necessary medical procedure I
mean this could save
people's lives now A B is a little bit
younger you're what 30 31. it's never
too early to be safe is it never too
early
no why when's it too early I mean yeah
eight years old is too early Dan you
sick [__]
fair enough
when when do they typically start doing
it I I think feel like I've always heard
40 but yeah 40. but you know I'm 35 so
it probably is a good idea it's never
too early man and people are getting it
younger and younger because we're eating
all kinds of crazy processed food and
that's not an accusation against you Dan
you eat good
but a b what are your thoughts on this
uh necessary vital medical procedure
will you be joining me you know a lot of
people in chat are saying Haram so I
have to double check with uh my shack
I'll get back to you is a prostate exam
Haram why what the hell no there's no
shot come on I'm sure they want I'm sure
they don't want you everyone getting you
know prostate I think it's 31 in time
because it's just for fun at that point
so are you you are passing on this
opportunity of a free
convenient prostate exam
I'm gonna pass for now
[Music]
it's clear you guys don't care about men
I do I do I I not like me not like you
no no this is why you're Alpha men
they're doing it I don't make that claim
I don't like men I don't I don't make
that Alpha claim like you do so
Zach you're my boy you'll do it with me
right
you know I'm gonna say yes really but
who who's this doctor oh he's he's great
he was recommended by a friend of mine
who's a celebrity he is uh I'm just
saying I'm not gonna say who but a
celebrity ass she oh it's her doctor she
recommended and he does home visits and
he's like uh he's very good he's very
good he's still like a GP yeah he's a GP
he has his own practice he's a great guy
ah [__] I I want to say yes but I've
I've never in full disclosure I've never
had anything in my ass well that what
this is it's going to be a great segment
oh man oh I'll hold your hand through it
if you want I feel like I'm not gonna I
feel like I'm not gonna react at all
you're used to I'm like what's it like
how deep do they go I mean the fingers
oh you've done it love
yeah I was checking for a bunch of like
I have like stomach issues so we're
trying to like check through a bunch of
[__] it's not that bad it's really not
that bad thank you it's a it's a little
bit awkward right but but again we're
gonna we have to do this this is
something we need to accept on a yearly
basis
right yeah getting the exam not doing it
on the show with you no right yeah no
yeah I agree with the first part of that
although if you guys want we can do it
annually
I mean again well like I will get one
and like I mean you just said it this is
a second time for you maybe I'll feel
more comfortable on the second round I'm
being totally honest we're gonna save
lives with this
I hope so
I hope so people are asking who came up
with this idea I mean what do you think
perfect
I thought it's funny idea and important
it is funny it is funny and I like I
really like the angle of one-upping the
uh the alpha males by doing something
actually uh I'd like to see fresh and
fit do this right yeah
having the confidence to do that I like
to see Peaches and Cream do this
that's what I call now I uh yeah uh rap
battle rabble what do we call them
Babylon Babylon reach which I think is a
little bit better than peaches and cream
I don't know why just peaches and cream
I'm delighted by that it's funny
they wouldn't do that it's funny
uh so Zach you're with me in solidarity
people are saying Impractical Jokers did
it they did they did a prostate exam I
don't remember a chat I thought I'd seen
them on I'm I'm gonna give you a
tentative yes but I still want to think
about it okay okay thank you pencil I'm
in I appreciate that Zach you're
solidarity email a chance I might back
out but I'm willing
I'm gonna say yes now
I think people like peaches and creamed
and
for the thing is nobody would have known
what you meant if you didn't explain it
I know but it's just funny
they're peaches and cream
they're harmless it makes them sound so
harmless
okay that's fantastic Ian I have a
feeling I know your answer but I'd love
to have your participation
um yeah I mean I'm I'm leaning towards
the no would you consider it it's sort
of like a game time call yeah I'm not
sure if I'm coming off the bench I'm
like I'm there's a lot of jello shots in
the fridge
watch party I don't know it'll be a game
time call oh that would make me so happy
but I'm leaning to know I'm just gonna
tell you right now okay but you're
saying the door's open if Ian doesn't
like your butthole if Ian doesn't I'm
oh interesting you guys are really Gonna
Keep Me people like peaches and cream
Dan okay
I'll tell you what
if you're holding my hand through and
look me in the eye I'll do it so me yep
if that's what it takes that's gonna be
awkward as hell that's gonna be a lot
more awkward but I'll do it it would be
funny you want to give me a kiss on the
lips
just two men looking each other in the
eye oh I'm doing one of course don't do
that of course they'll do that okay you
don't want to look me in the eyeab
if I get it done
oh for your turn
by the way human Human Centipede that's
a that's a standing offer to anybody
that I will hold your hand and look you
in the eyes
okay I'll do it
are you in
he said that's what I'm talking about a
b dedicated to the show that's what the
[__] I'm talking about bro I'm dedicated
okay does this mean you guys know Dan
he's dedicated that medicine the night
before no that's for a colonoscopy oh I
see I see yeah it's just transfer it's
yeah it's not the same do we have to
like like I'm you know my ass is clean
but do we have to do like a like a no no
no it's not like that okay how do we
decide the order because I don't know if
I want to go last we can discuss
whatever you guys want is it the same
glove
obviously
no that would be uh
that would be surprising I will make
sure he changes gloves between uh also
the doctor will talk to you guys before
the exam um he wants to have a phone
call with whoever's doing it so he can
explain to you what to expect and what
the exam fully entails can he do that on
the show I'd love for him to sit down
talk about the exam talk about the
importance of the exam oh cool yeah I'll
ask him now yeah
I have on the show can you take me to
dinner first or sure
I'll do whatever it takes man for you
guys to ensure your guys's Health and
Longevity
how long is the finger in the ass dude
it's quick it's in it's out
what if he finds something wrong that's
it but that's good I mean that would be
like wow brings up at that oppress love
would get a great highlight out of that
yeah yeah juicing oh yeah diagnosed with
cancer live on air
good that would be heartbreaking be
horrible but [__] great that we
probably saved whoever's life
yeah I mean I guess ultimately
good to find out uh cam I haven't asked
you uh working my way over to cam
um you know I actually haven't seen a
doctor in probably like nine ten years
now holy [__]
um Now's the Time
you can ask him anything let's see what
else you want while he's here the
doctor's gonna scare me for the reason
that I might be sick um right that's the
Paradox right if you never find out it
doesn't exist exactly yeah mind over
matter not really but um
I I think like Ian I'll take a
a game time call on that too I think
when the doctor's here you guys will see
how professional and how uh
just how comfortable he's gonna make you
guys I think that if I if I see that you
know I trust you but you know I if I
think if I see that it'll be the game
time call for me and I'd I'd like to see
you do it first I feel like I okay I
don't want you guys to like get cold
feet when I like you know get the finger
in my butt and and squeal like a piggy
[Laughter]
I'll commit baby I just I want you to
look me in the eye so you can see the
dedication I had to this show I believe
it as it's happening I want you to see
the dedication I'm there man right in
your [__] soul
oh God window the Soul's window Souls
window
to the soul
I'm kind of curious if anyone else
agrees with Ian order matters here Order
matters a lot okay so so what's the
story uncomfortable being last which is
the worst order to be in
Christ last last is the worst why I'd go
first I just feel uncomfortable with his
finger being in all of your asses but if
you change the glove it's a glove it
just still feels tainted no gloves
love come on now I mean the doctor
directly after you know how many hours
exactly sure but sure it's just like a
little bit of a cooldown could it be if
you use like another finger or something
like that uh wait Metro oh I mean he
does have messages
I need to call out fresh and fit like
the ice bucket challenge while the
fingers in my butt
it will be like Eskimo Bros which is I
don't know the term for it we all have
the same finger in our butt so wouldn't
you call that not as longer Bros
it's warm so it's more of a warmer
climate probably than the ice the ice
units or the Eskimo
jungle brothers from the desert rose
well it's it's moist and warm more like
a swamp it's Swamp Brothers yeah
bog bog bog bros we're bog Bros you know
that sounds like a website
so okay okay good so I'm actually this
is better than I expected we have one
confirmed yes from a b and we have
tentatives from three of you guys right
which is fantastic really wow you done
better than I expected me too I'm so
excited about this you guys I really am
and uh it's going to be for the the good
of all mankind
yeah
Chad is going crazy with Nick men's for
us Brothers mud brothers that's [__]
nasty I like hunger fellas
that's good bam
mudbuds hey photos on a plate hope today
in the lovely flight attendant saw I was
watching the Zach lorevid and she said I
love H3 but she fell off after TP I
didn't hold her against her peace and
love Fam thank you Harrison
that's a shame
what a shame we lost a good one
wasn't just five percent that uh we lost
that day right
oh well we didn't lose the five percent
that was the problem right that would be
right that was the problem yeah
okay hunger FF I think you gotta like do
your whole [__] you gotta go like
elbow deep on him
oh speaking of hunger FF he sent us
a prototype or photo
he made a dildo in the shape of his
fully prolapsed
uh anus or or colon or whatever you're
sure it's a a dildo it is yes well I
thought at first it was a Fleshlight
because there's a hole on the top but I
so I said where do you put your dick in
and then Zach confirmed he's in touch
with Hunger FF that it's a dildo it's a
little confusing because it's so fat it
I don't understand the image confused me
the uh apparently from what he he told
me that um that's not even the full the
dildo's not even the full size because
the manufacturer couldn't make something
that big now I've seen him prolapse and
I have to say although it does go out a
lot I feel like the dildo seems one I've
never seen him prolapse that long
it uh from what he told me he they had
to scale it down
um that's crazy well he's gonna come on
and plug it soon right yeah um that's
exciting let's be plugging it into
plugging it in he's actually the doctor
yeah
[Music]
he originally told me it was supposed to
be like a Fleshlight but he's thinking
that might be like a V2 people want you
to tweet it can you tweet it are you
allowed to share it yeah I mean this is
a this is like a prototype in
development still I thought so I don't
know if we can share it yeah no no I
mean I can I can ask him but um
I think maybe we should wait till he you
know Thunder yeah yeah but it's really
exciting I'm hoping we could get Howie
on the call I definitely want to get him
one
yeah I said one for the office one for
Howie for sure
so that's exciting news going to the
office oh man we gotta have like an easy
way to cover it when we have like a
guess that we don't want to embarrass
ourselves well I don't think they know
what it was
we'll see we'll just see what it looks
like I guess because it just looks like
a giant like slug yeah ow if you don't
know what it is
but um
there's our boy hunger FF friend of the
show always Trailblazer
or in this case ass blazing which we
like
we love that for him so okay lots of
good stuff coming up
very exciting
oh has it been 30 minutes already uh it
has I was actually just going to type
that so we don't have a sponsors today
so what I would like to do is on me on
episodes we don't uh am I I
it already happened what happened
we were about to say we were going to
try inserting an ad at the 30 minute
mark
well I clicked it thinking it would
bring up a menu and it just does it
oh it just did it without me even
announcing it I'm sorry I did I didn't
know we've never done it before so I
didn't know how it worked I thought it
seemed like it was a menu and then it
just said add inserted
so how long is it I think it's just a
normal mid-roll so probably like 30
seconds or something oh geez and then I
guess people with premium are still
watching yes yeah it's just confusing
never ever do it
sorry guys I did not expect uh you
really didn't just drop it on you no no
everybody's so confused I'm sorry sorry
that actually wasn't what I was even
gonna say is ad that was Dan I was just
uh I'm sorry I was just trying to figure
out how it worked can I ask you guys how
long was it
I we've never done it before yeah and I
know on Twitch
on my the my friends who do twitch
the ad roles they do is like a
significant amount of
um revenue for them
somebody said it was only five seconds
so that that what the [__]
you know
we lost a lot of viewers bro
yeah we lost like 3 000 people that
might have been people uh hitting
refresh too it might go back up in a
second but yeah that's it's chaos this
ad break is absolute chaos holy [__]
okay a lot of people saying five seconds
three seconds it was just like a tiny
tiny little bumper at I guess well then
if it's just five seconds who cares I'm
seeing
five to Fifteen I've even seen some 30s
but most five to Fifteen I guess maybe
it just varies per person dude we lost
sorry about the thousand people yo oh no
that's [__] that is catastrophic
uh that's not what I was gonna say
that is one of the things I was gonna
say is that if we don't have sponsors
uh we can have 30 minutes just run an ad
or something like that the other thing I
was gonna uh just do a nice juicy shout
out for in lieu of sponsorship is for
our memberships right uh the benefits to
being a member on the show is great and
getting greater
every week
uh you're gonna get BTS every week
curated by the great why are you saying
that a b we've just had a conversation
about it right before every every other
every other week that's what I meant to
say is every other week
seven days a week
a massive catalog of uh of BTS how many
do you have probably oh we have almost
50. oh wow is it really that high holy
holy [__] 50. I added up quick 50 videos
and there's a lot of really good
exclusive BTS content in there uh
besides that you are going to get access
to the Tuesday only members show that
happens every Tuesday it's a solo stream
with yours truly see you next Tuesday uh
it's a ton of fun we're also going to be
doing crew reaction videos to the lore
videos because when we uh were watching
it collectively
we all had so much thoughts and comments
looking back nostalgically the crew and
so I think we'll do an installments of
30 minutes or so a a group reaction we
can probably start we could probably
film the first one this week
tomorrow after leftovers yeah
you get access to Discord which is a
Vibrant Community of Super Troopers lots
of good stuff there participate in chat
and polls also Early Access to Live show
tickets
last time we did a we're about to launch
our second live show right we are we uh
we're honing in on the date I don't want
to say what it is yet because it's not
and not everything's been signed but um
it seems
like it's all going to uh click into
place in the next couple days so
probably next week we'll announce it now
the last time we did it they sold out
before the members bought them all up so
it is a it is interested in joining on a
live show
uh that but there are more tickets so
frankly I don't know uh what to expect
because last time it was live
600 uh it was more it was closer to 700
but yeah this uh this venue is uh I've
doubled the size this is the one that we
did in last time yeah somewhere around
there yeah
so there it is
um also uh this does not go to support
bbtv at all
also you know that stream where we're
like damn this money's all going to bbtv
I confirm with them they're not going to
be uh they still owe me two payments
they're not gonna be taking any of the
money
and most importantly it goes to
supporting the show so thank you guys
um thank you to our wonderful members
makes such a big difference and I'm so
appreciative uh to you guys uh so and
then I was gonna say Roll commercial but
Dan you already did
yeah my bad and it was a catastrophe it
apparently it was a terrible idea uh
it's already gone it's almost back up to
where it was that's [__] awesome
uh so there it is so thank you all right
let's see we got let's move on to some
fun Goofs and gaffs there's a new
Mobility Scooter out I mean that's
pretty good it's been a while it has
they become rarer and rarer I feel a lot
more fun yeah what is going on is there
less possibility scooters out there is a
covid less people out and about because
the people on the scooters are the ones
that die of covet right
I think you know they were they were
standing down in solidarity of Mary she
was like the only one you know she was
leading the way it would just feel wrong
to go out on a raft long live the queen
yeah we're all lost without their leader
disability Mobility so this looks like
it's in Costco so it's already looking
like it's gonna be pretty good
now this is whoa this is a Mobility oh
my God this is mobility on Mobility
crime
it's it I mean oh no that dude was
standing he's gonna need a scooter after
this
oh my God again I'm fascinated because
like these are really dangerous
machines evidently being driven by
people who are not always but sometimes
completely dysfunctional and not
reliable and like after
getting the Gatsby and seeing how it
works that thing is devastating what's
scary it's scary but B you really have
to go out of your way like
if you just let go it immediately comes
to a stop so like when people are like
running away like that they have no one
to blame but themselves well they're old
they just they push they get confused
and that's what I'm saying yeah it's
like like they try and make it as safe
as possible it seems like and it's still
not enough we need the speed limit and
stores
we need like a two minute or two mile
per hour speed limit right this guy in
the peach shirt is like a unit too and
just goes down he is man he's a thick
boy
you get like dragged under the damn
thing I think he actually rolled over
him dude I I think that's his whole
family they're all wearing Peach his
wife his son and they all go down wait
okay the lady
he took out the whole [__] family
right oh [__] I'm trying to zoom in on
like bowling pins yeah well do you guys
see what happens the the mobility
scooter is too back heavy so he he pops
a wheelie if you look really close he's
running over the guys well he has things
on the hanging behind there that pops
his front wheels up you see that
he's leaning back I need I need somebody
to upload this and so we can watch it on
slow-mo
because I I feel like this requires a
deeper analysis okay so here's the dude
and his wife he definitely takes him out
at this moment okay now this is real
interesting how she she falls back for a
long time takes up the other Peach shirt
guy knock it over my wife and then it
just Cascades really
he has like bags on the back back of it
that makes it too back heavy it's so
funny you think so yeah look at he pops
a wheelie before he hits him let me see
there oh yeah yeah yeah dude what are
you doing you're popping wheelies yeah
it's too back heavy that that means he
hit the gas like oh yeah this thing's a
freaking street trying to get out of the
street residents spit flame from the
back of that thing
so there it is you know it's always nice
to uh
to hear from our scooter I don't think I
can slow-mo this one down
uh I guess you would have to download it
and then play it
can I open it
yeah when you drop videos I am Discord
it's like impossible yeah you can't like
pop it out you're right it's annoying
okay so he he floors it
here he's about to so now he pops a a
wheelie yeah you can already I think you
can already see the wheel coming up like
right away so it's like instant wait
wait hold on is that his caretaker
behind him with the black hair I feel
like she might be could be let's see how
quickly she reacts
uh not very quickly it doesn't seem to
care he's just panicking her shoulders
are raised she's shocked
boom why is this video not longer
that's so I'm saying if you see an old
person specifically old in a in a
wheelchair walk around them big circle
around them because these people are
dangerous not just not a wheelchair but
one of these right a scooter a scooter
give it up give it a wide berth these
are dangerous man
and I've seen enough of them to know
either we need to outlaw Scooters or
outlaw being old
it's up to Senate but the Kevorkian bill
we need the quote the cohort getting
Bill the Kevorkian Bill oh [__]
okay
also
um in other news at Coachella our boy
PNP
uh the legendary was getting
I saw him with a few people but
this is
uh David let's go VIP area at Coachella
look my client here
so like I just had to beat the
my someone slipped or something I
negotiated the whole thing she walked
out they're in a in a paramedic uh going
to the hospital but we're out here
having fun
I feel great thank you so much PNP saved
my life wet and Reckless who everything
jaws of life police could not could not
arrest me let's go yeah dude David's the
man I'm actually super excited David is
helping
um our Nanny with this insane legal
thing that she's working through and he
saved the day he actually got her out of
this horrible thing nice I'm waiting for
it to be resolved and then I want to
sing his Praises but he you know I
couldn't find an attorney to do this
because it was like
um
unethical no I'm kidding
oh it was a tenant law tenant law and
the people that we were because she was
getting uh
she lived with this guy
and he was like a total psychopath
he was threateninger and scaring her and
[__]
and so she left from fear and he is
refusing to leave the apartment
he's there he's moving in people it's
like a whole [__] and she's on the lease
she's on the lease so they're like you
are responsible for this it's such
[__] and we're suing you yeah
and I kept going out I was reaching out
to attorneys and they're like okay the
they're like yeah okay the retainer is 8
000. I was like that's more than
the full amount they're asking for hmm
so um through David's help we're
actually we're able to get on top of
this thing he was the only one that
could help us he's my Obi-Wan Kenobi he
really is such a good guy man hell yeah
uh and he's been real real helpful real
available to her it's it's been it's
been impressive man love that dude
here's another fan setting of PNP
oh it's just a pick yeah we love him
David's out there folks he's out there
he's real
we talked about the Frank ocean disaster
well white clock Gabe was at Coachella
and he has some
some criticism for Frank Ocean he should
listen up oh
let's take a listen
I won't say Frank Ocean [__] you you
piece of [__] pray I hope Drake replaced
Frank Ocean next week
[__] a piece of [__] oh what a
night and culture okay
coachella's down a performance
you should give them a performance wait
did they drop Frank for the next week
well Gabe is offering his Services what
about your performance what for
Coachella yeah don't you think it would
be like a headlining type performance
what performance exactly look I'll tell
you what I'll tell you what I've been
preparing for when I when we when I play
on Sunday next weekend you can get the
prostate exam on stage yes that is
everything to me thank you metal as hell
talk about some butt Rock right there
dude you know absolutely
um
yeah
I hope I mean I don't know who's going
to Coachella next week but
what do you think Drake to replace
um Frank
Olivia's uh disgusted face
top five is Drake
Drake Drake
I know someone would be happy did you
see The Thirst strap that Drake
no I'd love to oh my God his towel was
pulled down so far oh please show me it
made me nosh
I find him to be so like
he just doesn't strike me as like sexy
or cool
he's so gross he's like such a goofball
he's like a goofy goofy
I mean like
what the [__] I guess I mean
you know
it's just something about him that's
just like seriously dude
is that really what you look like
and don't get me wrong Drake has hits
he's got a lot of hits
can I show this let's see
here's a drake thirst trap
oh yeah that bro I know you
that's not where the towel usually rests
like I know you orchestrated that he
pushed it
bro come on man
he is Jack though I'll say that good for
you he's goofy wheelchair Jimmy
while this person left a comment they
says 8.55 inches long 3.75 inches wide
uncut curve slightly to the left
tip is
f7b fd3 I don't know what that means
shaft is a creamy Brown four distinct
veins from the longest ranging from the
base to the tip on the middle right side
is this
excretion is macaroon cream and he's
trimmed but not clean shaven
[Applause]
I think
why
okay Drake
that's a tick tock comment meme I love
this when people do that oh this is a
copy paste
uh well people modify them for the
person so right it makes sense but yeah
it's a little bit of a copy pasta meme
that's pretty funny usually they do that
for women though it's kind of weird too
they measure what
and women it's their boobs or something
like everything it's not even funny
that's weird gross bad especially the
hex color thing that's kind of weird
I can see them being like she has
1253 eggs left sure
so uh there it is okay
now as you guys remember sunnyv2 is this
YouTuber that made this video about
Chris uh for Mr Beast that turned him
gay was insanely bad and everyone [__]
on him so we may this uh
Reddit user
nezi
uh made a super cut for our enjoyment of
all the vocal fries
there's there's no way he doesn't know
what he's doing right
yo this guy makes all these video essays
about people I want to know what you
look like first of all let's see your
face okay
and then I want to hear you not just do
weird voice over where it sounds like
you've had a stroke I want to hear what
your actual voice sounds like zesty
zesty
I my voice is stuck like this
22 pandemic I recently suffered a stroke
it affected my vocals
my speech patterns I could always stop
like that gay uh
there it is
this video I thought was pretty good I
wanted to watch at the top there's this
guy I guess he's like an alt-right
oh we actually they do know what he
looks like
this is what he looks like dork
hey yeah yeah yeah
I'm not gonna be I'm not gonna say
anything mean about him other than that
he's just dork zesty zesty
bro use your real face don't be a coward
talk [__] on everybody judge everybody
now I talk [__] I judge everyone but I'm
out here and all my friends all my you
know blemishes I'm out here fully I'm
about to get a prostate exam on
Wednesday okay
so
just saying yeah um there's this
alt-right troll his name is
Ethan Schmidt I'd actually love to do a
deep dive on this guy because this guy
is comically
he this man is barely he's barely
functioning his uh his brain cell count
is so low
that
I'm surprised there's any uh
intelligence at all behind there so here
he is in Barnes and Noble
making a stand against the LGBT Pride
Book display
uh
Ethan Schmidt if he has any other great
videos pull those up then
gay uh so here's Ethan Schmidt alt-right
uh
activist
sir uh do you have the a gay pride
section for children for children yes uh
I don't think we have one for children
now thank God thank God you don't have
one for children
thank you sir I'll see if there's kids
stuff yeah let's check it out though
let's make sure so he's walking around
with his homie it's Dumb and Dumber I
mean this this guy's dumber than the
this is crazy and [__] well there is
we're gonna have to complain to
corporate about that you can't take
their words for it
sneak stuff in like a trojan horse
he was the gay loser Pride section
got him
that's what he said
you all got him
he's like yo we got him gay loser Pride
section how old is this guy
I mean anything above eight is pretty uh
damning
oh we got him bro
gay loser price section
oh this these people are not even
listening they're minding their own
business yo did you get a load of these
gay loser Pride section dude crazy to be
gay huh
Excuse Me Miss isn't it crazy being gay
they're so weird don't you think
uh
surprise section
[Laughter]
I'm just really tempted just to kick it
down man okay I tell you what man
I just would kick down this display dude
I'm not but I I'm just badass dude I
want to tear up all these books not
going to do anything but I like to
fantasize about being badass doesn't he
have errands to run
yeah
how are we going to stand next to the
Gay Pride section at Barnes and Noble
block like security all day just kind of
Shuffle around I feel like maybe we
should do something more productive with
our time well Olivia you would be
disappointed to know that this guy makes
a hundred thousand dollars a month by
from the daily wire I am really really
really disappointed I made that up oh
I'm sure it's I'm sure it's probably
true he's probably a millionaire because
he's associated with some insanely
well-funded
uh conservative propaganda machine
yeah I love this it's a great show by
the way but thank you
so I'm just really tempted just to kick
it down man yeah [__]
I'm gonna [__] kick it down dude
perceptual don't don't
but I badass and I would I would do it
kick very unstable much like their idea
they have it right in the middle of the
store too just like a satanic he goes
very unstable like the ideology of what
being gay
caught him to hold much like their idea
they have it right in the middle of okay
dude
you don't look that balanced yourself
look at this idiot this he brings out
his his friend with him that's Dumber
the dumbest person I've ever seen he
makes this guy seem broken I'm just
really tempted just to kick it down man
stable much like their idea they have it
right in the middle of the store too
it's just like it's a tunic shrine
and now he's just harassing customers
like what kind of activism is this bro
I'm circling that table like sharks
man's just trying to get his Funko hot
right these guys aren't even you know at
least if you want to be brave go to a
gay bar and talk [__] and watch your ass
get beat the [__] up by some badass gay
dudes like you know don't be a [__] and
go to Barnes and Noble and like harass
customers and be like I would totally
kick this down go to a gay bar and go
tell them to their face that that they
suck that they're gay losers or whatever
and let's see how tough you are dude you
think that God Made You Gay there's some
dude you will get your ass beat out
there
little ass troll looking ass
it's projection though it always is
uh it always is excuse me y'all
vaccinated
y'all vaccinated
yeah yeah
[Music]
oh you all got the vaccine
wait how was he did we find out 25-ish
this guy's 25 now yo did you get the
vaccine
I don't think the last time I've done
that is like when I was probably 11 well
it's like a Ed Bassmaster sketch
I don't think I've ever done that I've
only seen Will Smith and Jazzy Jeff do
it fresh prince yo you're gay
they're like okay
by the way he's 25 yeah yeah that's it
for him it's that's amazing it's it's
solidified I hope he's good well what's
interesting is he talks about natural
selection and I don't see kids in this
guy's future anytime soon and this guy
has a girlfriend right so like if you
want to talk about natural selection
it's taking place right here on camera
natural selection this guy's basically
saying I'm never getting laid but this
guy is natural selection out here boy
the only time I get some is when she's
blocked out
um
yeah this is [__] great isn't it I
mean such stupidity on display is really
something yeah
natural natural selection
natural selection they said folks how is
getting the co like no ignoring the fact
that that guy's a girlfriend this guy's
Forever Alone
how is getting the kovid shot natural
selection I guess they're just saying if
you're dumb enough to get it that you're
gonna die off and that's you know that's
natural selection
I'm assuming
I mean does he know what it means
perhaps he doesn't know what it means
maybe I don't think he knows I generally
don't have a very good grasp of natural
selection I don't think he knows oh
maybe yeah I think he just heard that
somewhere yeah
right yes sir yes sir hey back me up Mo
isn't that right buddy natural selection
right yes sir yes sir yes sir we got him
brother natural selection
right what Ethan spit right yeah I need
you so this guy knows who he is somehow
yeah well because he's this is in
Arizona and he does this around whatever
town in Arizona he's in I forget
I I sent you a bunch more videos in the
Discord do you want to hear from Arizona
yeah I wish that this guy didn't give
him the satisfaction of saying his name
you know what I mean but well I mean
we're doing that well yeah but
I'm seeking him out right there's just
some random natural selection
right what Ethan Schmidt right yeah I
need you to leave whoa so if you would I
need whoa we got Kevin
Ethan Schmidt no I need you to leave why
you can't just we need to leave you
don't like Ethan Schmidt
sir
hey we exposed all your uh all your all
your woke [__] so we exposure
the [__] this giant display with
advertisements all over the middle
Library
uncovered the conspiracy bro he
literally goes it's in the middle it's
just wide open there in the middle and
he's like we exposed you brother that's
right I just exposed that couple over
there there they got covered shots
natural selection I swear if this
[__] goes into a Lego store man
oh it's Dawn it's over it's done for him
game over Dude
wait I think he has because I've seen I
saw something like that there was
something recently because yeah but that
wasn't oh I pull that up though because
it happened
wait did we watch it yeah I believe okay
yeah there was a conservative Freakazoid
in Lego who was like scaring the
children there [__] [__]
maybe you know it was on leftovers last
week you already exposed it so um
thank you thank you
[Music]
oh it's Ethan Schmidt
so do you think I figured out who you
were really quickly
[Music]
yeah they know who I am
all these employees of these work stores
know who I am yeah yeah dude yeah what's
not a woke store I'm really curious
he's That Bass Pro Shop boy I bought all
my accessories from them
it's the only store I'm left that I can
shop at
I'm looking forward Bass Pro Shop be
bringing up produce style so people like
me can do still buy groceries you know
these woke establishments
yes sir it's just me and the Bass Pro
Shop they got astronaut food
freeze-dried beans
cake they building a movie theater here
at the Bass Pro Shop so a good old boys
like me can see a film but all them woke
films ain't playing the only one on here
that play is The Passion of the crash
boy that's just on repeat all day
brother
and Schindler's List
that's right
oh so Charlie Kirk actually posted this
like it was a w
which is [__] crazy this is the
gayest generation in American history
that's truly now notice how and this is
a dub according to Charlie Kirk this man
goes why are you wearing that PIN
you're promoting and then he goes on to
describe
super graphic disgusting sex acts in
front of kids so if like again
projection you're a [__] creep bro
you have no problem
[Music]
the question is why are you all
with those pins on do you think children
care about what man sucks at home so
again it's like you are accusing them
why how dare you use that language
around all those families that's
disgusting and honestly the people that
work at the LEGO store are literally the
nicest people you ever saints they are
so [__] nice
yeah they're nice to you Zach yeah a lot
of VIP VIP I got Ian in the VIP Circle
too well I go there a lot with Theodore
Theodore loves the LEGO store so I can
vouch they're all super fun they're so
nice the vibe in there is very wholesome
and very welcoming to everybody and just
really nice because like they're
stress-free environment you just want to
build [__] you know like like they're so
nice you get some [__] [__] these
boys
yo dude what's up yo you really think
these kids want to know about sucky dick
no but he's building his little
ambulance set over there he's not we're
building a [__] [__] Lego [__] you
know here's here comes another one what
girl eats vagina you think these kids
care about women who eat vagina eat
vagina you hear me boys girls I said eat
vagina
who's the creep bro
clearly you do you think they care about
myself man I mean do you think they
think they think about that personally
right
they think about it when they see your
opinion they think this think about it
now that you're screaming at the top of
your lungs this guy thinks this guy he
thinks that when you see a pride pen
the first thing you think about is
sucking dick now brother I hate to break
it to you but that means that you are
readily thinking about sucking dick way
too fast
you know that's a you problem again
[Music]
you know what's amazing most children
don't know he's been educated yeah he's
he's creating a really nice environment
I'm sure the kids out there feel really
safe and comfortable with like security
there and this guy yelling obscenities
yeah good job between your legs good job
by me I think it's groovy it's brought
around pedophilia and child abuse
are coming in here talking about dicks
and vaginas
dude it's just like that is like the
happiest environment for like for me but
for a kid you know like what are you two
I mean this is the result of of the
conservatism in America today this is it
this is what it does to people it's
[__] pathetic
it's insane yeah it's [__] disgusting
and at the same time kids buy from the
store when does it start I'm sick and
tired
yeah but I probably just go I heard they
have like a not a Lego knockoff Mega
Bass Pro Shop Mega Bloks Mega Bloks
they're super homophobic over at Mega
Bloks it's called straight blocks we
these blocks are straight As It Gets boy
no dick sucking or vagina
associated with this here blocks
straight blocks we sell straight apples
we sell straight clothing this hat says
I'm straight damn it on it it says to
the world so they know I'm straight
so nobody ever thinks I'm gay
um
to buy something when does it stop at
some point we need to stop pushing this
mess on children at this point we're
just gonna have to ask you to leave I'll
leave okay and I won't spend any money
at liquor I'm sure if you're in here
Lego's suffering
probably one of the most profitable
successful businesses in the world
selling toys these guys are like
business tycoon Geniuses they're right
now
gbtq behavior on children sir spend your
money in a place all right all right why
is it that the police are shooting
people dead and this dude stopped and
shot and killed yet
get out the taser get out the riot
shields let's taser his ass and just
pull him out from the feet that's right
let's taser him bars
I want some I want some police abuse up
in this Lego store right now
no all right not defending a guy but
maybe they were sold out of the new Star
Wars helmet oh maybe that's why oh would
that be really upset it would be very
upsetting I wouldn't go full homophobic
but I'm saying you know I feel that I'm
just saying yeah uh somebody said
accurately in the chat they they for
sure he's never bought Legos and I I
that's not he he's not in the key
there's no age not in the club he's not
VIP no coming away yeah not until
there's like a storm the capital set or
something there you go here is Nancy
Pelosi's desk with a [__] on it
straight blocks from Bass Pro Shop
that doesn't do that to kids sorry
you're about to get trespassed thank you
all right well done Patriot
well done so remember Charlie Kirk
prominent conservative figure founder of
a huge conservative uh
Turning Point USA put this out as a dub
the question is why are you all in here
with those you put this out
as a dub go friendly this person looks
it wouldn't harm a fly my man's just
making his minimum wage in his Lego
[__] apron like let him be yeah he
doesn't yeah and he he's every person
that works there is like so passionate
about Legos like I I gotta defend this
I'm sorry it's pisses me off
I love your passion for Legos man thank
you means a lot you got your card on you
Zach your Lego card
I don't uh you don't have it where does
the membership work because I always say
no but we do buy a lot of them you
should get the VIP dude dude with the
benefits start the ad music you get uh
give them the pitch with the ad music
okay hold on one second
go to lego.com Zach if you like Legos
hey
hey everyone it's big Zack from uh Lego
Store here exact um big Zach if you like
uh well if you buy a lot of things there
you get points and you can get free
gifts when you're VIP Ian signed up to
be a VIP yesterday he got two free gifts
two free gifts
it was like an ambulance or something I
don't know oh that's cool but but Ian do
you want to say what kind of set you got
yesterday I told you it restocked yeah
Zach is just sitting on the Lego website
like all the time and saw that the BTS
Lego set restock so I bought it yo
that's a collector's yeah I snagged it
quick are you gonna build it are you
gonna like collect it I'm unsure I kind
of want to just hold on to it that's
gonna be what BTS Lego set that's dub is
it back to background family is [__]
dude oh they're still in stock oh they
must have made a whole hell load of
those
they probably made a million of those
damn things
yeah it's such a great product it
promotes like creativity and thinking I
think it's such a great toy for Theodore
to play with he loves it he's excited
about it it's wholesome
here is uh back to Ethan Schmidt my boy
uh he's now
let's see harassing a worker at a dog
adoption table over Pride themed pet
toys uh oh
these dogs are turning gay
I have two boy dogs and they're
constantly humping each other so I don't
think I've heard the pet groomers before
but this is getting ridiculous
this is getting out of hand I'll tell
you what man I got two boy dogs the
other one humped the other one
I gave the other one up I took him
straight to the pound I said ain't no
gay dogs in this house brother sadly my
mom's a queuing on Father I've been
trying to get her to go to therapy for
years some of the people some of the
stuff she believes insane these people
are brainwashed I genuinely think people
that are steep into Q Anon have they
must have some kind of
like paranoia personality disorder
and they're all out there's a bunch of
them because in America you got over 300
million people and they're all out there
and they're all on the internet and they
all the all these people with person
paranoid personality disorders are all
coming together and converging on this
thing and then they are uh confirming
each other's paranoia yeah they juice
each other up like back before this [__]
people were just crazy by themselves and
then they're like okay maybe maybe I'm
wrong because the whole world no now
they have a group they have Facebook
groups
it's power of the internet baby
oh
oh hell no
it's doggies what is this dog abuse I
mean if you think about it the dog is
ripping up the pride heart
I did not [__] my dog okay I mean I
didn't I didn't ask Jordan
that was not the time
how come like it's a gay pride for dogs
also This Woman's at like a volunteer
dog uh shelter
doing something good and then this is
what this guy's doing with this time
when can dogs be good
yes oh yes oh does he not know
oh yeah dogs are definitely can be gay
also dogs can't read you [__] dumbass
all right I don't even think they can
see color yeah they see in black and
white
this guy's just wrong across the board
it's actually incredible what the
hecking dog
oh that's inappropriate though you know
we shouldn't have that here you know
you're indoctrinating the animals bro
that enough
it's very inappropriate
I hope this guy doesn't have many fans
because my God you can look into it I'm
curious I mean this guy's gay as [__] he
walks around all day just thinking about
get Pride
this man is so gay he's the gayest he's
gayer than the gayest man in the world
is he always wearing the same like white
h m dress shirt too I think these videos
are just from the same uh stream I'm
pretty sure that it's just wander around
the mall and harass employees day this
[__] hits up every store yeah
damn yeah because there's another one in
here that I believe is also from the
same mall where he uh goes in to build a
bear to uh find something to yell about
in there that's great those are fun
Russell the bear
there it is he uh sure showed them they
showed them got him
Ethan Schmidt everybody and then we have
one more
um
here he is uh the Build-A-Bear
again a kid's toy store
uh
and build a bear
Build-A-Bear we're gonna see if they're
woke or not folks
we're out here to build a bear
[Music]
hello it's like excuse me
well you know you can put like a perfume
in the bear this is a little bit gay I
gotta say you putting perfume in these
deep bears
oh you put you stuff it with cotton
stuffing sounds a little gay
pronoun pin
what is what
is I'm really cool here we go we found
something I really don't understand what
it means we bounce out in the latch on
here
she's actually giving like a thoughtful
like caring response she's going into
the back to get her water bottles they
went to the back to get their water
bottle that doesn't make sense
that doesn't make sense like okay well
hey went to go like the world the world
is sometimes a confusing place my friend
you know how do birds fly
I want to hear his rationale for why it
doesn't make sense I really I'm very
curious
[Music]
uh if like someone
dropped something and it got left
somewhere yeah and you didn't know what
to want to it's like oh I hope they come
back for it right because it just
belongs to one person but you don't know
who it is
what about it
it
okay
he's flabbergasted because there's such
a reasonable response he's like yeah
he's getting schooled up what do you
even say
he's just really not that confusing you
say they all the time I'm predicting
that he's just gonna be like
let's see okay
okay I just find it still strange
you guys don't support them it was a
little strange but that's not that bad I
mean after a while it won't be right and
then after a while it won't be that
strange because you'll get used to it no
seriously if he thinks that's crazy
magnets are nuts how do they work some
crazy the world is really confusing I
know what he means
Build-A-Bear
well you know it's it's uh oh we caught
one boys
this is Easter so I just want to let you
guys know that you know Christ is lower
than you know hopefully you guys find
Christ here at Build-A-Bear all right
Christ is Lord Christ wins God bless
Christ wins God bless you know build a
bear I'm walking in Jesus's footsteps
out here brother
now what if he was alive today he would
be right beside me
I'm sure of it
he's a fine Christ
uh Build-A-Bear is super woke up this
[__] idiot is still with him
these [__] gonna build a bear like
with this button-up shirt you look like
such a freak with no kids yeah no kids
pedo Vibes
with that muscles this is just all bad
boys
though the bear needs to find Christ
uh Build A Bear Soup oh [__] we gotta
send in the link I forgot we got lost in
the uh conservative sauce there
did you have it
uh well I need to send him a link can
you can you put it in WhatsApp and I'll
send it to him
there you go
yo I literally live by that mall in
Arizona Arizona sucks
well
don't say that why are there good times
in Arizona me too anywhere from Arizona
for the most part
one of my best friends childhood friends
their family moved to Arizona so I used
to go visit him out there all the time
so I spent on good amount of time in
Arizona
fun when you're a kid in particular like
we lived in the Sedona area lots of like
hiking and like rivers to go play around
in and stuff it was cool
uh got lost in the sauce a little bit
here so Ian is gonna call in here talk
about Creator Clash a little bit
[Music]
you know you know what this video
reminds me of hold on he's he's doing
Aquafina that's gotta be woke
uh they look up Aquafina I guarantee
Pride yeah go ahead uh cam uh it's it's
not quite as a political spin on it but
have you ever seen this video before I
just dropped it in Discord of these
things oh it has very similar energy oh
it really does let it play at that time
stamp right there wait what I don't
remember this it's just two dummies in a
store being idiots
I have not seen this you have we watched
it on the podcast
and then the crazy thing is because
teams are so old he's got to be in his
30s in this club is there pinwheel
Stakes
like I said there's not a political spin
on it
two idiots going through the store or
being annoying yep with horrible facial
hair I kind of have a video
there that idiot in Costco
I assure you the video is extremely
different yeah you weren't knocking over
[__] oh yeah guys
wait what
dude
oh my God are you doing the Myspace
mirror pose like
you got money
are you a [__] pedophile well
keemstar is living the dream he bagged
himself a
barely legal uh girlfriend and uh we're
all proud of him for that
no their guy only used me blade still
does that kind of stuff and so his life
is so sad it's like horribly sad uh 16
is the age of consent I'm surprised man
I'm surprised that he doesn't have
better prospects uh with the resume he
has when you go below 16 like 15 and
stuff like that that then you know by
all means so the
nwba uh did a pride uh celebration
sponsored by Aquafina there it is I knew
it well and I'll add to that even more
over I just looked up aquafina's own by
PepsiCo uh which has a bajillion Pride
events and corporate Prides this is it
you you're putting yourself in a box bro
you're not gonna be able to escape I'm
just living I've moved into Bass Pro
Shop
it's a One-Stop shop for all straight
men it's just a bunch of men living
together
doing everything together we shower
together we change together
we sleep together we eat together
just a bunch of straight men over here
at Bass Pro Shop doing all kinds of
straight things
that's right
so somebody tell him that Aquafina is
woke
this man's about to die of he's gonna
die of thirst he's gonna be out and
about and he's not gonna be able to
drink water
the Tagalog language doesn't use gender
pronouns
so it's not even a new thing these
people just need more culture yeah of
course
of course
so we're just hanging around for
for Ian hopefully he's still available I
kind of [__] up uh he is and he is in
the lobby shall I let him in are we
ready yes please all right stand by
oh they have a Bass Pro Shop Hotel
for all things straight we gotta go
though I don't know if that is somebody
talking over the top
what the [__] I think so yeah
that's just a store in Memphis wow Sam
and I have been there that's powerful
right where the [__] do they sell there
they can be building pyramids like
they're Pharaoh there's so many things
in there there's like a uh there's a
bowling alley oh so it is a straight
Super Center hell yeah uh but here's uh
uh Ian and anisar with us
sorry
sorry for being so tardy I got lost
in the show here but yeah understandable
oh we're here to talk about our woke
liberal boxing event
yeah
do you does your boxing event stand for
LGBT uh Ian and Anissa it does next year
we're going to be handing out pins
ah that lib that damn gay agenda
dude you look [__] up how are you
feeling good
it's uh I'm a little less damaged than
last year
um no you're a lot less damaged oh yeah
I'm a lot less damage she says last year
he looked like Goonies yeah last year my
nose was like a lot more swollen now I
just got these pretty little things
Alex was pretty uh pretty good I mean I
didn't know what to expect from him but
but I guess he's he's not bad huh yeah
he takes it very seriously uh I think
hondar was training a lot with him and
he was telling me like yeah I mean he's
he takes it seriously
uh which is why we you know wanted to
match up you know he's a really good
competitor
and I gotta say myth I don't know he's
he's like the scariest dude out there in
my opinion yeah you it's funny you said
we were watching uh a b talk about his
fight yesterday and you are correct that
myth and Nathan like myth and dad would
be a mismatch for sure oh yeah thank you
for back all right
myth would kill him yeah
hmm
yeah I don't know man but uh well first
of all congratulations the it was
amazing um
the the arena stadium was freaking full
that was crazy
yeah it was a lot of fun this year we
had uh all the uh people in attendance
with like wristbands so there's like a
cool little light effect out there in
the audience
um oh okay cool yeah and that changed
depending on what was happening in the
show uh yeah so twerp twerp did the
opening song for Creator Clash we have
like a Creator Clash theme song Let's Go
I love it so good so do you guys have
any idea how much money you guys raised
this time
probably gonna be another
three extended pay-per-view for like a
week this time
um but we did we had very bad uh
pirating issues this year with private
discords so do you think that so when
people pirated I wonder is that are you
really losing Revenue I don't think
those people would have paid for it
otherwise I'm just curious your thoughts
because I've always wondered that
it's hard
yeah I think
I think you are losing a bit uh I I feel
like
it's part of the reason why I think a
lot of people have like chosen to do
things like this for free is just so
they don't have to deal with like the
consequences of it being pirated even
though it's cheap you know we try to
make it as accessible as possible but uh
I I think the pirating issue was uh you
know do you have any idea how many
people were pirating it there was a
Discord a couple of discords
um we're kind of getting reports back
now but there there were a couple that
had 30 000 people
yeah
so
you know is what it is
um what can you do about it though even
not much I mean we had lawyers this year
but with private discords it's like
what are you gonna do yeah it's an
impossible battle honestly
but uh anyway congratulations
uh thank you let's see a b poor a b you
know
ah
like I really thought he was kicking
dad's ass and then I don't know what
happened it turns out I don't know what
happened I mean well I I will say when
we were listening to AV talk about it on
your last episode like he's absolutely
right he was I think AB you were saying
like your punches were landing and
you're like this is like
this is strange or whatever it's like
yeah that's that's kind of exactly why
we thought it would be a really good and
even matches because Nathan is very like
very forward and very in there and
a lot of the time his head is very
available to punch yeah
no I thought I I thought it was a good
matchup
um I got unlucky but I I am curious to
see how it would have went but it is
he was tired he was scared yeah I I will
say that Nathan said to me after like
almost directly after he said I can't
believe I did that to Matt last year
like I've never felt a real punch before
and a b made me realize how much I don't
like that
and how much that sucked he's like I've
never been hit as hard as AB heavy yeah
he told me that that's never been hit so
hard yeah no you you've got him good man
you were [__] him up but that was
good um I'll tell you the other fight we
talked about this a bit but the the
girls who fought that chess girl
damn they were crazy their endurance was
nuts man
yeah they I'm really proud of both of
them I think uh Andrea was you know she
was up until I think maybe a month
before was undecided on whether or not
she wanted to wear headgear and she
decided last minute no headgear so I
mean that's pretty cool props to her now
Ian at the end of the show your opponent
Alex graciously
and uh uh full of emotion started saying
we need Ian to fight again
now at that moment you were crying you
started to cry and I wasn't sure if it
was because of the amount of stuff
you've been through or because the
thought of fighting again was that
terrible
yeah I mean it's just yeah I've
definitely uh I don't know
the it's pretty rigorous to go through
this year after year
um I was kind of pissed at Wasabi for
saying like yeah let's do it again yeah
like what the [__] bro you could use
like talk to me beforehand to him yeah
yeah let's plan this out no it was
extremely sweet and I'm I'm super glad
you did that because it is it does mean
a lot to me
um I think Alex and uh deji uh deji sent
me a voice message over um Instagram
along with Alex and they were both like
incredibly sweet and uh you know
encouraging to like keep keep trying and
uh you know push through
um
but I think I mean I'm gonna fight again
for sure you are I think my plan yeah is
to just take this next year off and kind
of
you know help out some more Fighters
give someone like the main event slot
because I think that's important and I
think there are a lot of people very
deserving of it uh you know myth has
been like you know like you said going
hard so versus someone could be really
good yeah
I really want Anthony Padilla and odd
ones out
that'd be fun I'd like to watch him
yeah
um but you know I will I
I I I don't know Ian I feel like
my opinion as a friend right you guys
put together this great event
maybe just manage it because like you're
just a normal dude and like I don't know
that it's good no but I'm serious I
don't know if it's worth going out there
and taking all these hits to the head
for like I don't know man because like
you know you saw how freaked out Joe
Rogan was over the dad fight last year
the the
Gula magada or the yeah
no but we need to protect your pituitary
gland uh yes now dude my pituitary gland
is solid he's had zero brain issues dude
he's getting punched in the head it
doesn't matter you know what I mean like
it's not good for you now listen uh Alex
was like he was talking about in this
like uh pre-fight interview he's like
I'm athletic I've done athletic things
my whole life I uh played on football
teams I ran I did this and that he named
all these things you know what I said I
played World of Warcraft
right and that there's a reason that I'm
I'm really good at soaking punches is
because my head has just been resting
for these past 30 years right yeah you
do too yeah yeah yeah I I've been
storing up like a lot of brain usage so
I'm gonna use it we have a theory that
your eyes are deep Set uh which is why
you can take punches like so crazy
you're you really are like Homer Simpson
in a way when you fought Mike Tyson
yeah
a bit better no you look really good out
there I mean you put you [__] them up
too but that being said but that being
said Ian you know
that's just that's my thought I don't
know you know I I don't you know that's
sweet I appreciate it yeah as a friend
that's that means a lot to me you're
concerned and I would say the same thing
to a b but I don't think he's fighting
again I'm out
thank God actually actually I don't know
if it's too soon to announce this but uh
I'm gonna be fighting salt poppy next
year at the career Clash three it's all
Poppy's a little free because though I
do it I'm [__] up salt puppy versus
dad is a fight I'd watch that don't put
dad through that
sprinkle the salt on his corpse
okay but so you are fighting again okay
yeah yeah
that's smart that's smart is that
because Alex did he [__] up did he [__]
you up be honest
uh I mean no worse than big big Dr Mike
did I mean no and the way he was like
one one more one more oh no I was always
going to take another break we we've
been grinding on this for two solid
years and uh I need to make some videos
and
uh start making money again so maybe
yeah um explain why you cried because I
feel like people might be kind of
curious well yeah I was gonna get to
that uh to the end there uh was a very
emotional uh scene for a lot of us
uh they were interviewing you and uh you
seemed a little bit speechless a little
bit emotional what was going through
your head
uh I mean it's it's kind of weird and
vague because it's like just a lot of
different feelings uh
obviously one is like relief that this
whole thing's over two it's just been me
you know running really hard not
focusing on uh you know I I'm gonna be
honest I don't love boxing
uh it's I I find it to be very
challenging and very difficult to do
um and so it's not you know when I go
into the gym every day it's like not uh
therapeutic or it hasn't been very
therapeutic for me
um or fun I've had there's moments you
know where it's like oh I'm doing well
today awesome but uh it's it's been very
hard so uh just like relief that it's
over uh you know stress from the event
accumulating because we had you know
plenty of drama
and uh you know just criticism and
everything online it's just like it all
kind of builds up and it's like oh [__]
like at the end of this fight a lot of
that stress is is now like is now gone
or like [__] exiting my body in some
you know in in the form of tears I think
also though the contrast between what
you see online and like how people are
acting in person watching you oh yeah
that's a big one I mean the the entire
audience being as like in in Alex
himself uh everyone there working the
event they're they're real people
they're real human beings who are like
being very enthusiastic and uh
supportive compassion and supportive uh
about the journey that I'm on and all
these people are on so it's like it just
felt crazy feelings I don't know it's so
much love in general just like from
everyone I think it's such a stark
contrast from the online yeah
stuff uh well one one comment you made
that really stuck out to me was you said
something like I know I'm not everyone's
cup of tea but thanks for your support I
thought it was a little bit sad that uh
you felt the need to say that and coming
from me I've been through that this
whole kind of thing uh of like
Fallen fans you know what I mean
uh
but it seemed like a lot of the motion
was coming from this idea of oh I'm not
everyone's cup of tea where before you
used to be kind of universally loved or
at least respected
and now and in the same way I've
experienced it like uh because you're
you don't because you've changed in any
kind of way uh they see you as like a
Trader or something I mean that that's
hard
um
yeah I mean I I guess I I said that for
for pretty much everyone you know like I
I think
I don't know I've been doing a lot of
growing over the you know
these I don't know my career on YouTube
so it's been
uh I don't know it's been uh difficult
I've had to like face a lot of things
I've had it like face the you know the
the audience that I've I've built and I
it's interesting because I had like a
viral moment on like Anthony Padilla's
um uh sit-down interview where I was
basically saying that like you know I
saw the fan base that I was cultivating
and I think a lot of people saw me say
that
um as like a like a me disowning my
former fan base or like you know turning
my back to them or whatever and it's
for me it was more like no I I was I was
disappointed that I
um you know went as far as I did with
things and I know I'm aware that I I'm
the one who like cultivated that fan
base and was just disappointing for me
to make that realization in person with
a lot of these fans that I would
interact with and uh you know they were
essentially holding up a mirror to me
and you know it was that was tough to
you know realize so the cup of tea thing
was more you referencing people that
you've hurt rather than the people that
you've left behind as in like yes people
that you've hurt with your actions in
the past that's a good way of putting it
yeah well yeah I feel you're getting
[__] like from reactionaries and I feel
you're also getting [__] from people who
are like uh looking at some of your
older content that's
you know made it was made then to be
shocking and super offensive and uh
again you're like a real person I had
the same thing I cultivated a similar
audience and I had it there was a moment
in my career in my life when I looked at
the people who were like retweeting me
who was commenting the comments and I
said these [__] people do not
represent me at all these people suck
like these are gross ugly people and I I
frankly like uh
I don't think I can continue doing this
with these kinds of people and uh it's
yeah I know exactly what you've been
going through you know and uh
it's hard
it's hard yeah but but honestly you know
you get through it
just yeah you just be true to yourself
and well I can see that just looking at
your chat your chat is like the [__]
digital equivalent of that Arena the
other night I'm like all right I'm not
gonna lie Ethan I go to your subreddit
all the time for like a a break from the
insanity it's like the only sane place
on the internet I swear to God that's
the first time I've heard that wow
that's wow
you should see what my Twitter looks
like because at least like the people
that are having a discussion rather than
just I don't know well Twitter's a
[__] nightmare dude because like
Twitter Twitter's just being taken over
Honestly by reactionary freaks like I
don't I don't spend almost any time on
Twitter anymore yeah
it's just a [__] nightmare there dude
but
we do have a great audience I agree and
I've been real fortunate enough to kind
of
through all that of changing
and growing and learning to have
cultivated an audience that
knows about my history and knows about
my flaws and kind of accepts me for who
I am and everything so that I I don't
know for me that's all I could ask for I
think that's that's amazing and I see
you going down the same road
yeah I hope so I mean I I
uh I don't know it's it's inspiring to
you know to see you and and the whole
crew uh you know build such a nice
Community I
I look forward to doing that for myself
in the future
well
I mean dude the Creator Clash thing is
pretty epic though I won't discount that
yeah no true it's just I get it I get it
once a year I'm like oh sick yeah yeah I
know what you mean well here's a comment
from bougie items was a huge part of my
teenage years of people actually stuck
around with him you'd see Ian if people
actually stuck around with him
you'd see Ian grew and matured as well
as we all do Ian saved my life
you believe that
question that sometimes when they say it
to me
I will say
um one of the fighters that we had on
the card
made uh both of us cry in public we
weren't expecting they gave us a car
both cards and uh the cards are very
heartfelt and uh we decided to read them
in public which was like a huge mistake
but um they I I believe when people say
that they mean it
um I have a I have a hard time accepting
something that big it's like come on no
I I didn't save your life you're a part
of probably a lot of things accumulative
that gave them uh some relief when they
needed relief that that I'll buy that
that's kind of my my whole mission
statement what I do when we set out to
do this podcast I had a vision to do it
five days a week as uh to as a companion
something the to get people through the
week you know to keep them company uh
these are the kind of shows that I
listen to that I love so that's but yeah
I accept that you know we'll get you
through the week but saved your life I
mean come on
I've I think I've gotten that's one
thing I've I've changed a lot with over
the years is not realizing that every
when people say things like that they
don't mean it literally often okay
they're being very passionate you saved
my life yeah let's do a poll how many
people in chat's lives have I saved
because because according to this chat
I'm basically like Schindler and you
guys are all my little Jewish refugees I
think a lot of people actually mean it
you know they go through a lot of stuff
some people you know they they just want
to have that like Community you know
people that they can rely to listen to
every day so they don't feel alone
I guess there's a cynical part of me
that uh
is just unable to accept that high level
of Praise these glasses have changed my
life you save me from the streets of
Detroit that I believe yeah you owe me
everything
uh well 65 of the audience says I've
saved their life so
when when is my sainthood
when is my sainthood uh being uh
announced by the Pope
yeah but so
Yeah you mentioned you got to start
earning money again are you guys not
earning anything right now no no oh boy
we're we have not earned money for the
past two years which makes taxes very
easy that's good
we love that easy taxes I like the I
like looking at the bright side of
things
uh so what's your plan just get back to
work on the idubbbz channel uh yeah
doing that there's a lot of other side
projects that I've been abandoning as
well me and my uh business partner
Justin we got to start working on uh
pocket squirrel our video game I
remember you telling me about that years
ago is that still in production oh yeah
we're grinding we're grinding away very
slowly on it
did it ever stop production or it's been
in production steadily it's been in
production steadily we'll take you know
nine month long breaks you know what I
mean okay that's not super steady
uh this he's an artist yeah the guy
who's making the the game I mean he's
very good at what he does and he kind of
he keeps changing it you know we have
one thing that we like and then he goes
no no it's got to be this and I mean we
kind of let him do it because he made a
game that you know came out of nowhere
and made him a millionaire so we're kind
of just oh he actually made a successful
game in between the time you guys
started it yeah yeah oh [__] so he's
like [__] this dumbass project
yo what's the chances of that what game
what game was it uh Katana zero yeah
it's on uh
oh I think it's probably on a lot of
platforms it's very loved holy [__] yeah
no this game's dope whoa It's got crazy
good reviews wait what the [__] I've
never heard of this it has like crazy
good reviews
wait what kind of game is this a
platformer yeah it's similar to like um
what was that roguelike that you offline
Miami or something like that um well
there's that too but there's one that
you got super obsessed with uh oh yeah
uh uh zero zero cell
dead cells there it is oh yeah yo can I
play Katana zero on the steam deck
because that's what yeah oh for sure God
bro I'm about to pay your homie yeah yo
that's so crazy it has like 50 000
reviews on Steam yeah no it's very loved
and he's I mean artist for real like
he'll he'll make you know 90 of the game
for us and then he'll be like no no I
gotta redo all this and we kind of just
let him do it so that's why it's let him
cook yes well that's exciting I mean
[__] now that he has some credentials
people are gonna be really interesting
people I'm seeing people in the chat
saying could Tana zero save my life it's
good it is
awesome oh here's a nice comment though
says Ian didn't save my life but he
definitely helped me grow into a better
person I wish I could give there was
more I could do to give more thanks
I love that you want to drop your PayPal
yeah handout
um
I wonder if you guys can like
sell Creator Clash almost and get a
Payday that way well we we've been
offered already yeah yeah
by Fox Fox whoa
we said no seven figures
uh
like low seven figures
a few of them
I mean I don't know what it was
specifically it didn't come directly to
us it came to one of our business
partners but we said no and we're we're
never gonna do anything like that just
because it's it's too special it loses
its Soul you guys do need to be making
money though you understand that right
it uh I don't know according to a couple
of YouTubers were pocketing 1.7 million
dollars so what's the calculus on that
one well they thought the production
cost of the event was a hundred thousand
so
just in total in total the whole thing
that's amazing that'd be great well I
can tell you how much it cost even we
did like a we did the show for like 700
people across we ended up spending like
twenty thousand dollars well for yeah
production is not cheap and uh yeah as
somebody that comes from a broadcast
background I I will uh compliment you to
on the production of both the first and
the second Creator Clash
um you know especially the main event
part um was really smooth and I thought
it was run really well so thank you
thank you Dan you're the best we added
more staff this year so everything went
even smoother and the head of
broadcasting he's so passionate about
the project I love him so much and uh he
really loves doing what he does and this
year he really made sure he talked to
every uh you know fighter and made sure
that their dreams came true for walkouts
and we had uh wonderful yeah they were
so good we had this uh uh a woman
working for us this year Alyssa who she
wrangled all the talent and made sure
everything was smooth it was crazy she
had a lot of like
she's a fan of the show too and a legend
oh yeah let's go she I left my robe in
the stadium and she brought it back to
me at the hotel oh they're nice yeah so
sweet
last time we had you guys on after the
first event though I said you guys gotta
make money have you not changed anything
since then
um maybe next year we'll we've talked
about taking a salary
next year because it is more than a
full-time job I mean we did you guys not
take a salary at all
uh no not last year this year we're
I don't I don't think we will
I don't know we haven't it won't be a
big one if we do it's very it's on par
with every other you know employee
it's kind of the Oddish but
um
I don't know there's we gotta look at
some numbers and stuff before we make a
decision on that yeah
yeah we just got to figure it out it's
uh I mean we're we're not in any
financial trouble it's just obviously I
get to take this you know year off so
we'll be fine yeah let's just start
grinding we'll focus on YouTube and
other things but next year we'll take a
we've we're reworking the framework so
we
you know are basically our co-workers
are making us take a salary next year so
that's fine yeah I mean
bro oh my God see you guys say the chat
is the chat is [__] annoying me right
now I want to go stop talking about
money Ethan I was like what the [__] you
guys aren't interested in money like you
act like I'm the only one shut the [__]
up chat
they're annoying as [__] sometimes too
uh just so you guys know I was gonna say
you it kind of feels like you I mean you
do like I don't know
I feel like you would have a lot of fun
talking to like a financial person if
you brought like a
like a a gram Stefan or something like
that on your podcast because there's so
many like I don't know interesting
little discussions to be had you know
around real estate
money I'm not I'm not I don't care about
investing all this [__] I just want to
know how you're doing is that crazy
what the [__] I'm with you that's like a
huge part of everyone's lives yes well
you need to make money to survive and
you're not the only one that's talked to
us about it stupid ass dumbass chat
idiots
it's my [__] show let me ask what the
[__] I want
uh yeah no that's valid that's valid
yeah but uh
but um
well yeah we just know that we're very
like we're very aware that we're we're
fine and we we can do this for a few
years without taking any sort of salary
so don't why would you do that I just
don't I want you to I want you guys to
take care of themselves yeah yeah well
we we are taken care of we're good we're
smart we're adults but why are you gonna
dig into your whatever okay see y'all
forgot my head because because our
savings are very
are stuffed our savings are well stopped
so I I'll leave them all from it
we're very uh I think we're just very
inactive and frugal people like we don't
we don't have a uh our house is meh or
we drive a Subaru that got [__] a
couple years ago and haven't fixed it
like and and we're fine like we don't
neither of us really care I just don't
think we're really okay
they want to know if you're fighting
with health insurance
it's last year are you [__] crazy you
don't have health insurance
what the hell you guys are wild [__] for
that the event did the event had health
insurance like every fighter just they
were insured they were insured health
and life and like when you get checked
you get like a little sheet that's good
for a month you can just hand it in and
you'll get care for free oh
um just pointed out what you're wearing
Ian thank you
hell yeah thank you buddy you got the
teddy fresh beanie and the team
Starkiller
yeah he loves that beanie so much he
wears it every day is that right yeah
we'll send you some new stuff we've got
all this great stuff coming out we'll
send you guys a whole package oh yeah oh
we everybody loves your hair too Anisa
everyone's talking about the blonde hair
it looks perfect yeah yeah e-look
message me oh she did yeah
you know this is a little bit of a
personal question but I am curious about
it and feel free to uh here we go not
respond to it but I know you had um your
breast augmentations removed yeah
recently and I'm just curious about that
because you got him in and you didn't
have them for that long yeah and when I
saw you I met you guys in person a
couple years ago and you're very excited
about it so I'm just kind of curious
what that Journey was like for you
um I think the biggest thing for me that
I'm finding out now as an adult is that
I'm like almost 100 sure that I have
autism yeah and uh I'm very sensory and
I should have known this about myself
like I can't have fake nails or fake
lashes or extensions I always get really
uh antsy I don't like the feeling of
something that isn't
apart it's just a sensory thing so I had
these implants in all the time and I I
told the surgeon I was like I like how
they look I just I I can feel them all
the time and so uh the surgeon told me
like oh you'll forget that they're there
in a couple months and I definitely
didn't it just like got worse
um to the point where I just like I I
needed them out of my body and it's not
like I think it is specifically like a
sensory thing for me ah interesting
where I just couldn't do it anymore wow
so so so now that I guess you got them
out you feel all everything's all good
oh good
it's kind of a win for me
for me I really learned to appreciate my
body just feeling good and not worrying
about
you know it looking a certain way and
now I feel like just thankful to have a
functioning body which is kind of cool
interesting
well there it is that's a whole journey
uh
fantastic
so
chat's [__] annoying
stop looking at it yeah but I want to
say um so you guys are about to start
screening for uh number three recruiting
you have interesting people reaching out
or the ideas formulating
yeah I mean even before this event ended
we had people
like a list of 30 right wasn't it like a
list of 30.
that's exciting
um but you know what keep going man you
guys have you guys built this really
incredible thing
and
it's enough just to focus on it in my
opinion because it really is a good
engine you guys are raising a ton of
money entertaining lots of people these
communities are coming together it's a
nice thing you know it's a really nice
thing so
I congratulate you guys
thank you Ethan that means a lot it
really does mean a lot there's like uh
you know there's some people that I
really value their opinion and
definitely you and elar to those people
so thank you and thank you to a b
sacrifice these past two years
[Music]
our boy but his pituitary on the line
for you that's right yeah thank you guys
it was uh life-changing it was the most
awesome thing I've ever been a part of
so thank you
yeah and uh now that AB is officially
retired if you guys are looking for uh
another ayad Lena has uh expressed
interest in fighting I would love that
there are there I have some girls that
are very down and I I would love that I
think I want to have at least half the
card be female fights yeah that's what
we're shooting for this upcoming year
half uh half female half male and uh
maybe even if it sounds well sounds like
the woke agenda oh my God I would love
that I really would I've been boxing
lately and I just love the sport and and
seeing the girls at the actual
um at the event it just got me like so
pumped I really enjoyed it oh yeah and
to be honest like I was gonna say like I
I think Anisa is like probably a better
fighter than me and
um it might be the same for uh avian
Lena Lena might be a better fighter than
AG so well you might actually get like
Lena Lena in this office is known for
surprising us all she has like this
crazy Joker brain energy so I think I
think that she might her opponent might
actually die yeah
like aniso was an athlete in high school
so I I wasn't but Lena did uh
varsity basketball oh nice okay and Lena
you've you've been you've been boxing
you've been practicing yes how long have
you been practicing boxing um it's been
a few months now but not every day like
Abby was doing just a few times a week
um
how tall are you I'm five four
and you're how much do you weigh 120
yeah
it sounds like it sounds like your
wife's about to get in the ring baby
oh man now you get to be on the other
side of it EB yeah that's fair it's good
for ab to experience that
this is an interesting comment from
Bella Simmons she says love so so much
all the wholesomeness came out of
ricegum being too scared to fight you
true
um wow that was yeah that's interesting
huh
someone said Ethan would you fight if
you were the headliner I don't care it's
not the headliner it's the fighting
it's not the it's not my order in the
thing it's the actual fighting itself
that's the problem
well that is an interesting detail I
think a lot of people uh or a fair
amount of people this year were kind of
like either upset or concerned with like
their position in the lineup
um you know before Main Event because a
lot of people think like that that
matters and maybe for traditional boxing
it does but for our event it was like
the same amount of people from when the
doors open until they closed so it's
also like because ours isn't traditional
I'm I'm trying to Pace the fights in a
way that like keeps people engaged
because it is five hours of fighting
dude the event was long as [__] dude you
guys oh my God that's the longest boxing
event of all time I mean what the hell
it's like five hours long yeah we're
doing 10 fights next year Max how much
was this one 12 yeah
and there's about 30 minutes of run time
for each fight if they go the distance
right right yeah kind of a lot
people are saying Ethan versus Philly
Philly will not exit that ring man I'll
do what Dad did the I'll do what Dad did
to AB but but that with that uh
weak kidney of his he's not going to
survive it
oh God
well it looks like William Haynes was
calling out Philly D on Twitter which
was funny I didn't work with him William
Haynes yeah he's the one who beat uh
Chris Ray Gun yeah he's Source fed yeah
oh [__] up his former boss yeah I
love that
yeah but uh
well nice to nice to hear from you guys
congratulations on uh fantastic event
thank you
and very much looking forward to uh the
next ones you know
yeah yeah I would like for it to be a
yearly thing that kind of lets everybody
gather and feel good and
you know get your physical needs out and
you know build it up for another year I
don't know I think that's cool I want
that I want to just go as a guest and
enjoy it yeah yeah
we should when Lena fights we should all
go out to support her
I would love that I would love that
sweet yeah true yeah
it was sweet to see Hassan you know get
so excited about myth winning and uh
they put the spotlight on him and I just
thought that was oh yeah yeah I saw a
picture I saw him was freaking hyped
yeah Hassan hugged me after and he's
like uh don't worry bro I stabbed dead
in the hallway yeah
actually I feel bad because if I I can't
go next year I will be there
I literally I cannot not watch Lena
fight I would fight Bobby Lee but I I
invited him he didn't get back to me
nobody you guys can go to support Lena
it's just you know to be honest you're
there to support a b you know yeah is
this Partners in the ring you can be
there making sure right right it's hard
I S band was uh really trying to calm me
down when Ian was like getting
interviewed because I was having a
full-on panic attack I kept saying I was
gonna puke so s fan was like trying to
calm me down because it it's hard to
watch your partner do that it's so hard
can I show you a meme I saw on the
subreddit it's funny
I thought wait the H what the [__] is
this it's like a fake uh Twitter account
I'm logged in here
uh one sec let me pull it yeah it's just
a dummy account you know I was talking
to Eric uh comment etiquette and DJ
Welch and they were saying that they
thought they could just watch and enjoy
it from the sidelines but like seeing
all their friends in there made them so
anxious the whole time so I'm curious
how it would go
I was interested for your fight no I can
attest to that
hurt I was like what the [__] dude what
is going on here
I I thought there was a chance he would
die like I I know I'm just I'm just
concerned I thought he was like he
ruptured a a [__] organ and it was
gonna bleed internally we do have like
just a I mean I I know you probably know
this but we've got so many like doctors
and EMTs that's good everything you
could possibly need so you have
defibrillators there yeah
that's good we got all that
ambulance right there in the dock ready
to go that's good that's good we love
that uh here's the meme I saw on the
subreddit and uh listen no it's just no
offense obviously I mean we love it but
this is kind of
I just feel like maybe for the third one
[Applause]
I do feel really guilty when I saw that
Meme I felt so bad because it these are
my matchups and I I do want to say like
I really believed okay that like a b was
gonna shell up for the first round dad
was gonna get tired and then it was
gonna be extremely easy and everybody
would be like whoa like a b like I was I
was trying to give him a a soft pitch
okay but he went out there and he
started throwing hands like immediately
I was like oh this is really bad
um but he I mean you're still winning
but that he won that round no question
yeah
I was an unlucky uh unlucky uh body shot
you know yeah that was the plan Anissa
that was the plan exactly to the whole
time every single day I was training
head body head body while he was just
slapping me around hitting me and I got
in there and then I just [__] I don't
know I think it was the first time I hit
him and I saw like oh [__] like it was
his reaction I think [__] me up a
little bit that first good hit I got on
him and then just kind of all my
training went out the window even while
he's like why are you why are you
fighting like you're in the [__]
streets dude it was Madness yeah Madness
yeah
were you mad you looked mad you did you
looked angry yeah no I wasn't mad I I
you're talking about in the ring yeah
you looked pissed off when you were
fighting yeah
I'm
no I it's just it's just you're not used
to it I knew he was gonna come at me
like that but it's like okay we're not
boxing we're just [__] throwing hands
all right let's throw I don't know it's
weird it's a weird weird feeling but uh
no I wasn't mad after the fact it's just
like it just sucks to put in like so
much time
and know exactly how it's going to go
down it happens and then it gets [__]
up over something so stupid and what
really pissed me off is I was like
starting to feel better the next day and
I'm like [__] should I pushed it a
little longer like I don't know it's not
worth it I
if the chance that you were did have a
serious injury you know what I mean yeah
yeah worth it because you you need to
get that
I got less worried I was worried too
because I was like oh [__] like oh my
God and then I looked at Wally's face
when you were like on the couch and I
was like oh it's fine like because you
could tell that Wale was like
he had seen it before so I was like okay
I'm less
once the doctors left I was like okay I
think we're okay yeah I know like uh and
thank you and Easter came in the locker
rooms like checking on me
apologizing like it's not your fault
yeah and while yeah I know Wally like
usually Wally like if it's sparring and
I'm like hard sparring I'm telling Wally
like all right I'm out he'll be like get
your eyes back in there before I make
you do you know double the amount of
rounds but uh no this time he understood
he knew he knew it was a good shot and
you know if you know boxing it happens
one shot could [__] you up well when you
when you threw in the towel a b I'll say
this I knew you were really hurt because
I Amy's a fighter and he and I thought
he wouldn't have thrown it in if he
didn't have to I've never ever like
had to call it because of being her it's
always just like my stamina or something
you know after so many rounds I'm just
like [__] I can't even [__] move my
body but never has it been from being
her so it sucks but
could have been worse it's always like
placement two most of the time right
like it's not even like how hard you're
getting hit like a just a decent place
punch you know right in the right place
it just sucks
[Music]
so what's on the horizon Ian
um hot seat too oh yeah the hot seat two
with Dax flame we're gonna get a whole
new host of guests and is that grinding
those out
what's that I feel that Zach might be
your Muse in a way
Zach Dax oh yeah oh yeah he's amused
he's your Muse yeah he's my muse he's
your inspiration in life he's almost
yeah the reason for
you know working and getting up he's so
I I love Dax yeah I think for me it's
just like he's so naturally funny it's
like he's an absolute [__] like gold
Mind of a human like you you you put him
in you just talk to him in front of a
camera for an hour and you're just gonna
get entertainment like you know you can
put him in front of anyone and it's just
like everything that's sad is funny so
oh do you want to hint at maybe what
else you're going to do on your main
Channel
uh you have to say yes uh on my main
Channel I'm going to be addressing
controversies and I'm going to be
putting out
a I'm going to be putting out a Content
card yes
[Applause]
about controversy related to
controversies that might be nah yeah
yeah sure yeah yeah wow I am this is a
very vague uh tease so don't get like
too big have you filmed it it's it's in
uh are you is it being edited
now that this all this uh this stupid
event's done with I can focus on
uh my Pat my true passions making
content cops
well that's that's something to look
forward to that's exciting yeah yeah
you know all right
well guys
yeah thank you team uh well done
everybody good job guys
looking forward to uh oh yeah people are
saying it's disabled content caught on
H3
can I say that that's when I my fans
fell before your fans did my very first
video I made on YouTube on the
Starkiller channel was why Ethan why Ian
would never content copy you so and I
was wearing idubbbz merch with a teddy
fresh hat and so it's wild to be sitting
here with both of you now here you are
yeah
and what were you what was your thesis
uh may I ask I haven't seen that one
fat man good
is Batman good Batman good Batman good
yeah instead of Batman just Batman good
it's just [__] I don't know it's
been a while old drama well you see
there it is it's because we're friends
that's why yes that's the only reason
Ian yeah [__]
content caught your old self dude
all right thank you guys
I appreciate it nice to see you all uh
glad you guys are doing well and uh keep
it going man love you guys
love you guys thank you all right bye
bye bye guys see y'all
that's nice it sounds like they got some
good projects in the way that game he
told me about years ago uh the fact that
this Katana zero guy made it
is pretty promising
because the real deal
yeah now I gotta play it uh it's I've
had it wish list uh wish listed on Steam
for a year plus at this point
um I sent myself an email
to remind yourself together to get this
play the game because I need a new game
on Steam deck I played this [__] out of
Binding of Isaac right right I've got
like 200 yeah that seems it seems very
appropriate for steam deck
wow and also excited about that content
cop I think that should be interesting
uh oh yeah oh boy actually I have some
big news I didn't want to interrupt the
interview with it but just a little
update
on a topic for Monday
yeah whatever
[Music]
yeah it's all being reported that it's
due to an injury and I guess that's what
they're uh saying the problems on Sunday
was related to we mentioned that on
Monday uh are we buying that
I don't know
I don't know and look at this there's
even more breaking big news look at this
I just dropped in Discord big news oh
boy I'm breaking big news Okay this okay
interesting outfit choice there's oh
very interesting oh yes no pants it's
time to announce it I will be playing
Coachella main stage on Sunday wow very
excited that is a huge come up yes
nope dong out two dog out yeah dude
playing like flea Zach what are you
doing at Coachella with your pants off
yeah yeah but uh you know to summarize
this whole Creator crash Creator class
thing
you know Ian and and Anissa built a
really amazing uh thing here and a b uh
has also been uh incredible hard-working
he's getting his his job done and doing
training and getting out there and uh
it's it's it's a wonderful thing and uh
I congratulate UAB and them so well done
maybe thank you these path to uh creator
of classes thank you for the opportunity
it's been amazing
yeah good stuff man
uh well with all that being said
let's get back to uh
uh homophobic transphobic uh people that
want to uh
do terrorism
uh there's a question from the chat uh
that I just sent you Max Richie says uh
when and where does the Zuck is a
soul-sucking demon shirt come out oh
it's coming out tomorrow [__] I forgot
to mention that
dropping tomorrow just that shirt just
that shirt just that shirt I'll put a
note at the top of leftovers right now
it's uh yeah
I'm making Meats now I was gonna wear it
today I just forgot
oops I totally forgot
very good
um
let's see what else we got here
Berman Miller CEO does not care about
her employees wait we have another
um
we have another headline
that we should definitely get to about
how we oh oh Howie breaking news about
our friend of the show Howard yes Howie
if I may call him Mr uh Mandel okay by
the way I sent him a picture of hunger
ff's uh prolapse
he said thanks I don't want to touch it
well I told hunger that we want to send
one to Howie and he was very excited and
very thrilled and seemed very open to
the idea I wish I could show this to you
guys it's almost like it's super vulgar
but also not that vulgar because it's so
confusing looking
I don't I don't know if it's public yet
yeah it's not a matter of the vulgar
that we don't want to show it's just
that he hasn't let's get the hype going
for the for the well he wants to come on
to announce it right well yeah he can
he's welcome on whenever he wants to
what are you trying to undercut him man
it's not a big moment I'm I'm not big
moment [__]
it's a big moment
it's not easy
oh [__] I'm the I can't imagine how many
of those he's gonna sell so I mean I
already bought two of them which is
how many of you what's a production run
on uh on a prolapsed dildo look like I
don't understand it's like how many you
make you guys it's like this thick like
and it's not it's not it's shaped at the
top for like insertion it's like a blunt
object so I don't I don't understand the
logistics it's like putting in like a
like a four by four up your ass
you're not a size King like some people
so
right it's just it's the it's not the
size I don't understand I know that
there's amazing people out there doing
amazing things it's the it's the shape
at the top
yeah it does kind of look like this
girthy
very girthy yeah Frank wait what the
[__] wait wait wait what which one is
this I don't know God emperor of Doom
yeah yeah
okay interesting yeah it's a little bit
like that okay okay I like the analogy
visual cue there
yeah so Howie
went on Joe Rogan today
and while I'm very happy
I also have to say that
[Music]
he went against the family
doesn't he know that he's not allowed to
talk
to
um
Joe Rogan
yo this looks just like it like this is
this is basically spot on alone
I mean it looks like a [__] sand worm
yeah
I'm trying to find where's the Howie
stuff
uh here I got it
yeah it just was happening now we got
some highlights to watch what do we do
about it
but uh of course I'm just kidding
I'm just curious how we did on Howie on
uh Joe Rogan so for this first clip
um the whole clip is like six minutes
long and the whole beginning of it you
know is just how we talking about his
struggles with OCD and everything but
I'm gonna start it about halfway through
because it's when Joe jumps in that it
actually gets good
someone just suggested I fight Ben
Shapiro I said I'll fight Ben Shapiro oh
hell yeah I'll I'll take that fight I
mean he wouldn't do that of course not
go ahead what do we got here so here is
how we uh with Joe
so many in technology
registry and everything wait can we can
you look at this code real quick wait
did you guys check this to see if it
gets claimed
no didn't it happen last time we showed
it yeah and we're like what the [__] I
test uploaded uh the uh him talking
about Bud Light and it got blocked
immediately that is so [__] up
damn Joe you have changed
you've changed Joe
all right well [__] it
but didn't you think it was only like
100 re-upload like if you talk over yeah
that was because we continue to keep
okay we watched it yeah and it was okay
so go ahead go ahead let's watch it then
let's see
also though I gotta I Gotta Give It Up
to our to Joe Rogan for his recent uh
sipping of the Budweiser
the Bud Light in a courageous Act of
trans solidarity
except a Bud Light
they won the Nobel Prize
are you gonna pull it up yeah
right so here they're talking about
Howie Mandel managing his OCD and Joe
has some interesting advice for him yeah
for me I can't tell you I'm not that far
from that so I'm always just trying to
toe the line and be on this side of that
door you know have you done any anything
that else that helps other than
meditation have you tried um other than
medication have you tried meditation
I tried it I've tried meditation and
I've do meditation I've tried Medicaid
I've tried everything outside of the uh
and I'm not opposed to it
um the psychedelics and mushrooms and
things like that I don't know if anybody
would recommend that to you well here's
the here's the problem for me in order
to do that you'd have to get off your
medication right and to get off my I
don't know that I could survive that
bridge from my medication to doing that
so the medication is for me my my
lifeline
tripping balls during that entire time
would approach something like that
because I think you're you're dealing
with a very specific kind of case and
most of the people that advocate for
psychedelics do not advert Advocate it
for people that are really struggling
like mentally just to keep it together
right now you know and to get off the
medication which is helping you keep it
together it probably doesn't seem wise
but there's ways you can do it without
drugs and there's like holotropic
breathing there's some people who
practice I I have never experienced it
so this is me talking about my ass but I
have direct connections to people that
have done Kundalini Yoga there's a
specific style yoga specific way that
you can achieve I just love that how
he's literally like the whole beginning
of this clip is him for like three or
four minutes straight talking about how
intense his OCD is and how it genuinely
like he comes off as an app it was
actually pretty interesting to hear him
talk about
um how he comes off as very affable and
friendly and he gets along with people
but that there's like a constant
darkness in him that he's like battling
and it's really bad and anytime that
he's alone like his intrusive thoughts
and like all this stuff and then Joe's
like yeah have you ever heard of have
you ever
Ayahuasca you're not like breathing I
mean have you tried breathing but the
way he says it he's like okay well I
know people who cured it through a whole
trophic breathing what is that it sounds
like an Alpha Brain product also just
like breathing in a weird Tales very
very well that he has found what works
for him right and that's the other thing
is he's talking about how he has got it
figured out we're at the destination
we've arrived I was like I've tried
everything I've lived a long life of
battling this trying everything yeah but
have you tried holotropic breathing
because that cured my friend and I'm
just telling you man it's a therapeutic
breathing practice that is intended to
help with emotional healing and personal
growth it's said to produce an altered
state of consciousness the process
involves breathing at a fast rate for
minutes to hours wait is that what we
have a sound bite of Joe
is that him doing holotropic breathing
no this is him exercising is it it must
be just that quick breathing and I think
you just get lightheaded because you're
like your brain probably not it does
feel pretty good again yeah
yeah it says it can lead to dizziness
fainting weakness spasms of the hand
feet and even seizures so this sounds
like a good idea can cause reduced
carbon dioxide and other alterations in
blood chemistry
sounds like really dumb
dude if you if you force yourself to
hyperventilate
I think it could cure your OCD
and then the other thing he said is like
Kundalini Yoga I'm looking that up right
now but uh
has he tried three sips of beer Howie Ah
that's the real advice right there
okay is that it or is there more yeah
that's really it I mean I I watched the
clips and I mean we're just kind of
memeing when we say you betrayed the
family obviously
he would never he could never he could
never he's our uncle actually cam had an
interesting point because you know how I
always refer to Howie as America's Uncle
which I stand by
Camp went out Joe Rogan is kind of
America's Uncle too he's like he's like
the [__] Uncle that's there at
Thanksgiving that is really annoying
he's the uncle on the other side of the
family right you know what I mean it's
the in-laws like you don't really know
him right he has serious Uncle energy
too though I will I will agree with that
okay uncles we got Uncle energy
definitely his uncle nipples right
all right let's move on to uh but yeah
of course we're joking how we uh we love
you so let's see what other topics coach
we got to talk about the Coachella fail
yeah it's not that interesting frankly
they went over curfew and they got
charged 117 000.
that's it
that's the story
when you put it that way I mean that's
the story yeah I mean I guess so that's
basically
you know
big news 117
000 for going over curfew maybe that's
why Frank left
they're like hey just so you know you're
costing us like twenty thousand dollars
every five minutes past curfew
it says 20 they're charged twenty
thousand dollars for the first five
minutes and one thousand for every
single minute after
dude they make so much money though it's
like that's almost a value proposition
to them like let Frank finish his set
sixty thousand dollars right jump change
to them
I also just I mean Ian you were just out
there I mean how many people live in a
close proximity to where the event is
going on
uh I mean there's a bunch of
neighborhoods but I mean
I don't know it's once a year I don't
know yeah it doesn't seem that serious I
think they can afford it I don't know
what their revenue is but a thousand
dollars a minute seems like they could
go wild they could yeah they could yeah
they could tack on an extra 30. my uh my
grandmother lives probably about I don't
know
four miles away from the Polo Fields you
you could definitely hear it okay well
fair enough yeah I've heard some stuff
about her
billboard reports that Coachella earned
more than 114 million in 2017 I'm sure
that's gone up quite a bit since then
too sure yeah
yeah you guys would be fine
um
all right so listen Herman Miller is a
chair company and I gotta say I I use
Herman Millers I like her man aren't you
I am too you're both stands I wouldn't
say I'm a Stan I've heard you brag about
it brag about it like in what way no he
wasn't I I asked him about it I think
and he gave me his feedback
I just said it's a really nice chair
they make a gaming chair that uh you
know it's hard to find a really
comfortable chair as we all probably
know believe me
well listen dude that scorpion chair is
way more expensive than most Herman
Miller so you should be thanking me
that's a premium that's that's a premium
all right
uh
they made this gaming chair and it's
freaking awesome the Herman Miller
Logitech aiming chair
um oh yeah and body find it well before
you go buy it though wait until the red
you're the rest of the story I guess I'm
gonna burn mine in solidarity I'm gonna
buy I'm gonna burn the [__] that I own
already
here it is yeah so you you went out and
got one on our recommendation right baby
yeah it's a good ass chair right yeah I
love it yeah how much are they
um [__] I don't know they're they are
expensive let me see yeah
um embody game chairs Seventeen hundred
five thousand gone better be good it is
it is very good it is very good but uh
it's more than my car dude yeah
but yeah what can I say it's a good
chair but anyway let's see what uh this
lady's CEO has to say well on Zoom with
their employees Owen was encouraging
staff to hit a sales Target
before fiscal year was over
and Owen was questioned by employees
about the potential loss of their
bonuses here's her response that was
recorded
let's take a look
and this came through about
how can we stay motivated if we're not
going to get a bonus what can we do what
can we do some of them were nice and
some of them were not so nice so I'm
going to address this head-on the most
important thing we can do right now is
focus on the things that we can control
none of us could have predicted covid
none of us could have predicted supply
chain none of us could have predicted
bank failures but what we can do is stay
in front of our customers provide the
best customer service we can now she's
trying I'll tell you I bought this shirt
during covet because of my I was sitting
so much I was [__] thinking about
like I need a chair
so I don't know she also uh uh let's see
over the past few years she gets a 2.4
million bonus on top of her 1.1 million
fixed salary
last year she made 5 million bucks
which actually for a CEO is kind of
modest of a big company which is crazy
it is crazy yeah get our orders out our
door treat each other well be kind be
respectful focus on the future because
it will be bright it's not good to be in
a situation we're in today but we're not
going to be here forever it is going to
get better so lead lead by example treat
people well talk to them be kind and get
after it don't ask about what are we
going to do if you don't get a bonus get
the damn 26 million dollars spend your
time in your yeah she's an obnoxious
she's like uh
I don't want to say the b word because
that'd be inappropriate but she is
giving that
karenish I mean and again this woman
made five million dollars last year at a
fat [__] two point uh four million
dollar bonus
relax Boby Jesus uh see you women can be
heartless uh
brutal capitalist too of course of
course they can we love that for them
equal opportunity I love this this
insinuation that like how dare you ask
me about your compensation
it's like yeah dude there there's no
reason for them to be there they don't
care about Herman Miller [__] chairs
or their bottom line [__] you know
good for them they should be effort
thinking about the 26 million dollars
which is even not thinking about what
you're gonna do if we don't get a bonus
all right oh my god dude I hate her she
reminds me of uh Professor Umbridge from
Harry Potter like that evil Professor
one mustn't tell lies she like smiles
yeah as a soft voice while she's [__]
you up but like if she means what she's
saying just forfeit your own bonus
you know
2.4 million last year forfeit that dummy
[__] stop wait what was that who was
that [__]
I'm assuming that's Gabe
it's Gabe
wasn't me
can I get some commitment for that no
I had an old boss who said to me one
time you've convinced is that the one
that takes over Hogwarts yeah oh exactly
I mean
a little late putting two and two
together
any other hog uh Harry Potter analogies
we want to flesh out before I press play
um
nah
is it the lady that wears all pink yep
that's her okay thank you of course with
the ministry of magic too I believe
she was a big
what the [__] you doing [__]
you can't live there so people mystery
of magic is part of Hogwarts oh my God
you guys
separate there's this institution yeah
they're kind of like the police besides
come on I really want to focus on this
place they get involved sometimes though
with like right okay
guys I really just want to finish the
clip okay it's just Harry Potter people
aren't watching for Harry Potter lore
also people don't even like her they
want to hear they want to hear about
Harry Potter because she's a Turf who's
she JK JK oh ruffling ruffling like
rolling on the floor
[Music]
all right did we get all the Harry
Potter out of our system please never um
Contra points just dropped a good video
on JK Rowling not too long ago oh that's
right well let's focus on the video that
I'm oh no that's a good plug though you
guys can watch Poncho points on your own
time I I recommend it it was really good
yeah it's a good video you know it's a
great leaders when they make really good
videos the ministry of magic you know
Dumbledore and Snape you know I mean not
Snape uh Voldemort how is that even
relevant was Snape a member of the
ministry of magic no no no he was a
Death Eater uh but he's kind of playing
both guys if you guys want to do a Harry
Potter like sewing Circle book club
that's fine just not during the show
please
just [__] up Dumbledore is dead
like 20 years ago bro get over it no
he's not legends never die
all right this is real world [__] okay
like all right this is serious all right
let's focus
all right
right can I get some commitment for that
she kind of has Harry Potter glasses I
had an old boss who said to me around
one time I'm gonna kind of style that
Daniel Radcliffe
wearing I feel like she's exactly the
same but
he'd probably be in Slytherin right
this lady uh Hufflepuff what do you
think Ethan what house would she be in
I don't think it matters at all
but she'd probably be Slytherin
thank you I see that but I don't but I
don't believe it's relevant so I
appreciate moving on
time you can visit pity City but you
can't live there so [__]
[Music]
let's get it done I spend a lot of time
I've seen all the sights I holiday into
the city I have a time share are you
joking love that play stunning all right
and I get some commitment for that I
would appreciate
I had an old boss who said to me one
time you can visit pity City but you
can't live there so someone said that to
me I'd [__] lose respect for them
forever somebody go I'm going I'm waking
up and going to work for you and you're
gonna come to me talked about pity City
I will you know what I mean I'll go
melting them when you're making 2.4
million dollar bonus on top of your
salary and stock options and everything
else it's funny that she's so angry at
her employees for caring about their own
compensation do people leave pity CD
let's get it done
thank you have a great day oh my God
demonic and she did not just boom she
did demonic at the end there on a
serious note as someone who was five
years
in a office job being underpaid like man
when I started I was making like twenty
thousand dollars a year
[Music]
and um
I don't [__] care like I care about
doing a good job and being respected by
my colleagues and my boss but I don't
[__] care if you care about the
company in that way you're you're a
sucker yeah like you have to be very
real with yourself you have to respect
your time and your money and when it
becomes that time for the raise you
gotta be your own best Advocate because
let's remember the reason why you're
there
the reason why you're there
is to make money
and you get and usually you I don't know
how it works most companies uh I work
that have an annual review and at that
review you get one chance
to talk about money with them
the whole rest of the [__] year
you're working your ass off to make them
money and do whatever right you're you
get one chance to talk about money with
them and there's this uh
there's this perception in Corporate
America that it's like don't talk about
money don't talk about other people's
salaries don't be greedy
[__]
that sucker if you're being greedy then
so you know then so should you you need
to make as much money as you can so when
you get those reviews you go in there
for Ready for War and uh you [__] get
in there dude you know what I mean so
this whole this whole attitude of hers
is like makes me want to puke it's like
[__] you these people are not they're
not part of the Herman Miller family
their own stop okay you know what I mean
they're there to make money
some may some may like the higher
Executives or whatever but yeah like not
the sales people yeah yeah
you're really gonna mic drop oh God
she's the worst
Eve pity CD let's get it done
thank you have a great day
dude why why
she's doing it she's doing a spell right
there she really thought she did
something there borrow one of your
favorite phrases there I hate her
uh this says oh apparently
she received a bonus of nearly 4 million
according to this tweet
so there's a lot of confusion about that
we actually went out of our way to
untangle it um because people were
saying she got bonuses as high as like 6
million
um but we were able to find the
breakdown of her pay scale and there's a
lot of categories of income
um the bonuses for the last two years
amounted to that 2.4 okay which is still
a matter nothing to laugh at
I mean I'd appreciate some solidarity in
her forfeiting that
one way you could break it down
if you made sixty thousand dollars a
year salary
and you work for Herman Miller for 40
years
basically your entire career you would
make her bonus
oh that's pretty fat
just a whole lifetime just 40 years a
whole lifetime 40 years of work for
basically your entire adult life yeah
fire it's probably because she works 40
times harder than you at least I mean at
least but yeah yeah that is one thing
that I would give advice to uh young
people entering the workforce do not
undervalue your time do not let people
convince you that for any don't forget
why you're there don't let them convince
you or brainwash you into any other
[__] reason you're there
to make money
and when you get the opportunity to
maximize that you do it
that's it
thank you
that was my whole thing with it you know
I left my job because my boss was so
micromanaging and so fake and she took
60 Commission of my work
and it's not just worth dealing with
when you value yourself more than
accepting that that sounds horrible yeah
[__] that
it's also a really good job market it's
not like the Great Depression out here
where like you you know you gotta like
just be thankful you have a job type of
thing that's not you know it's a good
job market right now
yeah like to the extent that you know
the people that control the money in
this country are flipping out about it
because workers have too much [__]
leverage and it's a problem
Oh the the Starbucks is unionizing one
specific Starbucks store ah
yeah get what's yours kavish that's what
I'm saying she thought she ate so hard
at the end of that the end was so crazy
that she thought that that was like
awesome her words like it was written
for her by someone else I would like to
know the context with what she gave this
interview thank you have a great day
CEO douchebag [__] uh weekly
psychopath weekly
um
she clicked end meeting and she was so
proud of herself I bet
um and she thought about pity City
[__] that [__] that nobody's saying pity
to me and getting away with it none of
her employees hell no dude you know
we're in an office space where they're
like does anyone ask you is anyone asked
you on Monday if you have a case of the
Mondays
he's like hell no hell no [__] you get
your ass beat if you said that [__] no
yeah
it's that it's the pity City I'll be
there in pity City uh this clip caused
the internet to look into her own uh
compensation as we talked about
so she stacked and that's that
and that is that Jack
oh dude this YouTuber's arrested for the
car crashing [__] is crazy yeah
82nd response to employees bonus
question came at that oh so she played
that to employees you know she was
talking to employees in a zoom meeting
and somebody leaked it
it was a corporate town hall meeting
so she was [__] talking to
you it sounds like almost like she's
bragging to like a friend I mean how why
are you talk that's psychotic 80 second
response to employees bonus question
came at the end of a 75 minute meeting
that primarily focus on customer service
and performance goals
so is she trying to motivate the
managers yeah tell the sales people to
[__] off no I 100 what she was trying to
do was like because in the middle of
that she kept saying something like that
we got to hit that 24 million or
whatever that's probably like whatever
their sales goal is this quarter and
somebody asked about the bonuses and she
was like
she was basically trying to say like
don't worry about your bonus why don't
you just worry about hitting the goal
and then you'll get your bonus is like
what she's trying to say but it comes
across extremely College I'm just
curious who she's talking to though like
the whole company the whole company
because this is the call yeah she did
like the mic drop on her employees I
know it's insane that's like why like
she spat on them she thought she was
really you know giving them the give
them the motivation they needed I I
almost can't comprehend that she's
talking to the employees I thought this
was like a call with a few people uh but
this this is insane they might drop your
own employees but you can't live there
so people leave pity CD let's get it
done
thank you have a great day pity City
I'm sorry I gotta say it [__] we got
[__] gas to buy [__] we got
groceries to buy I think I drive out of
pity City exactly
commuting I got [__] kids [__]
because I'm not rich enough to live
anywhere else but pity city
are you serious right now and she's
[__] evicting me from pity City what
the [__] dude right there's no winning
so there it is
mic drop she's like basically [__] you
guys
do what I say we're lowering your pay
mic drop talk to the hand [__] you
all right I gotta pee and then I want to
talk about this um
this car crash YouTuber [__] it's blew
my mind when I saw it yo uh so I'm gonna
go to the bathroom I'll wait for Dan to
come back
I could handle it
okay
that's something important to say what
do you got cam
[Music]
hell yeah
I need more birds
also uh while we have this little break
I just want to say uh Zach will be Live
May 13th at the Roxy thank you very much
baby yes
how many times more are you gonna be
playing in L.A the last show dude this
is the last La show dude I gotta go I
got my ticket now
our tickets selling are they going fast
they're going like hotcakes wow yeah
that's hot yeah
and a majority of the crew will be there
as well so we look forward to seeing you
guys it's gonna be a good night
yeah how's everyone feeling everyone
doing good I'm feeling great I feel
reborn I feel different I feel different
are you sore or anything you're good
nowadays no I'm good that's good yeah
kind of wish I was a little bit more
sore because uh I don't know like I said
the way I healed so fast makes me wonder
if I should have went a little longer
but it is what it is you're just the man
of iron is what the thing is you heal
fast you're a superhero and I love you a
b and I'm so glad you're back and we can
hang out now that you won't have time
boxing in the gym oh yeah I miss you too
buddy Olivia how you doing
doing well thank you for asking how's
the rib rib is good the rib is good yeah
thank you you scared us
yeah I saw that I was watching back your
guys's watch party and uh I could see
the fear in your eyes Olivia it's tough
I don't like watching people I know get
hit
gotta have them ribs oh here comes Dan
is returning there he is Dan ladies and
gentlemen woohoo
now you see
can I can I say what just happened
okay so Ethan was trying to run an ad
but he couldn't figure out I came back
and I hit the button I was wondering
what he was doing I was looking I came
over I got scared he was cooking
something up over by the Scorpion chair
[Music]
um with regards to the background I'm
going to do some adjustments this isn't
the final thing I had to adjust it last
minute today
um if you'll notice the fire appears and
disappears at random times and I'm
adding little goose and gaps now [__]
badass cam this is not the final product
Chad Demands a bunny there will be a
bunny there will be a Jackalope I
actually saw a lot of Jack lope requests
so I'll put some antlers on the bun ham
is my favorite Bunny man thank you
Jordan
I'm excited for Friday Friday is going
to be an amazing episode
I don't know if we talked about what
we're doing but Friday baby we could
talk about it
we got a few things planned on Friday we
have the uh guess who's high again
again again and then also 420 Edition
and it'll actually be on 421 but um
uh too bad
we're doing it on 420. we celebrate weed
month here yeah right exactly it's weed
month
and also we will be giving
our presentations yes to what we believe
we should spend the uh BB TV money on
yes we're doing uh it's kind of like a
shark tank situation because we'll both
be here and everyone on the crew will be
presenting their pitch for how to spend
bbtv's money well no not BBT
the bbtv one right I should say and also
some of us
may be high
as we are giving these presentations yes
I'm right right which could uh
spice it up quite a bit as well I see
some people saying team Japan thank you
so much to all my supporters out there I
see you you are seeing it's so
appreciated I'm so thankful for all the
love that Japan gang is giving so thank
you so much to Japan gang shout out
we're definitely taking home the Cup
this year we're taking we're taking home
the cup
I'm I'm in a weird place because I want
that for you Dan I want that for me I
want to go Japan too but also I'm afraid
that one of the other ones may win
as a meme
and I'm
interested it'll be interesting we're
not leaving it up to a fan vote right oh
I thought we are oh God no if it's a fan
no we're going on whatever the worst
trip is if we leave it to the fans
they're gonna troll us so how are we
doing it Ethan and Ela Ethan and neela
oh okay they're not then never mind well
we need to figure this out because my my
presentation is very geared towards it's
hyper targeted to Ethan mode is the only
way you end up in Japan Dan that's the
only way yeah well actually yeah Ian's
right and also Mine The Only Way is with
the fan boat but for different reasons
interesting well I mean we could do it
that way but yeah that's gonna that's
gonna alter my my pitch we gotta ask
Ethan when he gets back what he thinks
yeah but Ethan won't accept the fun boat
he knows what who's gonna that's that's
what I yeah it's like ultimately he's
paying for it and I feel like he he
won't but he's a man of the people let's
see what he says I just did the cost
breakdown for my place I even called the
place wow
whoa I'm gonna need Ethan to be high
for my presentation
I think mine will be the cheapest
so you have I mean that's a plus
I don't know though I don't know if
yours will be the cheapest I don't think
everybody knows everybody else's but I I
know most of them and I actually think
mine is reasonable for what it is yeah
in the amount of people when we do the
here Ethan's back when we do the
presentations Ethan uh on Friday yep for
how to spend the bbtv money yep it's you
and ILO making the call right now it
won't be a fan vote
I mean I mean it's not
maybe we can do a fan vote and that can
influence your decision but yeah yeah
yeah I do I am curious what they think
right but it's I'm not gonna let I'm not
gonna be bound by that just because of
this there's certain logistical things
right
oh that's all I'll be overcome don't
worry yeah there it is so we'll see but
I do care about what the fan thinks for
sure okay but ultimately I do reserve
the right to uh
but I will I will be influenced by the
people okay okay and somebody else
saying it's really expensive huh
as long as it's under 6 20. so mine's
gonna be mine's gonna be the cheapest I
think but we'll see
I'd I'd [__] up add some Gatsby's to
it or something bro
Beef It Up this this is like government
spending if you don't use it right lose
it yeah do we have like a a budget we
need to work within no
well I'm 320 000 is the budget I'm
literally well I don't know how you
could possibly spend that much but I'm
willing to spend whatever whatever I
just don't know I can make it happen you
could spend 620
we could where I'm looking at we could
blow it out
we could probably at the place I'm
looking at we could probably get to I
don't know we could probably get to 300K
oh
I don't know what you're planning but I
I legitimately am down yeah this is bbtv
money like I just don't give a [__]
let's go right now oh my God by the way
I love the idea of bbtv uh like in
financial crisis watching us talking
about how we're gonna waste their last
their last crumbs of money no I'm just
kidding bbtv is a great financial shape
they shared me and frankly they were
able to cough up 69
000 yeah so they had at least that much
money that we can say for sure
yeah
I mean you gave it to him
I know I know I forget that but so I
just yeah I know it is ultimately should
have never been in their hands but it is
what it is
they gave it back yeah so okay Sam's
going big I like it all right
all right I like that
mm-hmm
so there's no situation where we can get
you
to partake at all in the festivities on
Friday
oh no no shot no shot
damn I'm sorry I just I I can't
I've accepted in my life that me and
Wade are just not symbiotic it's just
not a good match
fair enough
so my desire to uh smoke and enjoy weed
is gone
I am out on weed with peace and love
this is a serious message
I'll get paranoid the show will be
[__] weird I'll probably have to
leave because I'll just feel too awkward
and paranoid and the show will just end
because it'll just be weird and horrible
it could be interesting an interesting
experiment but I'm not gonna I'll tell
you I'm gonna peer pressure you it's
like torture uh it's it's truly like uh
will be horrible for me
you know you're gonna get a
pretty much fingered on stream next week
yeah
but that's cool that's nice totally
different yeah that's true clear mind
yes you know
one reason I really want to do it is
like for annoying family members that
ask so so what do you do out there in
California I want to send them the
timestamp of some dude sticking his
finger in my ass
it's it's gonna be good content it's
going to be good content
someone says try ketamine on the show
that'd be interesting
I don't think YouTube Dan when you do
ketamine are you like is your mind still
sound no
[Laughter]
because like they're either certain
drugs I assume like when you take an
opiate
you're high but your mind is still sound
you're not doing anything while you're
EX on like could you talk coherently you
can't even walk on it yeah so so yeah I
like I like yeah I'm not in so much into
tripping balls at this point in my life
have you done uh have you done like
um NOS like whippets
no I don't even know the difference
between a whippet it's not like that
exactly but that's like that's one that
I could like compare like the level of
you not being able to do jack [__] is is
comparable I would say Nas
are you taught are you talking about
puppets or whippets or snap-its
not I'm talking whip it's not not
poppers
pop it whip it all right now turn it
around yeah I remember that thing
Whip It
laughs
all right where were we going okay yeah
I want to talk about this uh I'm super
pumped though for Friday's show yeah
it's gonna be good we're gonna do the
who's High and the pitches I'm genuinely
stoked
and you know we have this vacation
coming up we're planning in June so we
have a time slot potentially where we
could make it happen you don't sing did
we talk about that yet our live show is
gonna be taking place
sometime the end of June and we are
going to be taking um
a summer break we're adding a summer
break summer break to uh our yearly
schedule let's [__]
we usually take uh time off at the end
of the year but you know
I think it's only fair I mean it's good
for me too I I want to spend time with
my family while I'm
you know yeah I mean we've been doing
that schedule for uh five six years now
uh yeah of just like having three weeks
off in the winter and so it's been years
since we've been able to like take a
trip or do anything summer related you
know what I mean so uh we talked about
it late last year and Ethan was in
agreement that that sounded pretty
freaking sweet so yeah the live show
just like uh just like in the winter how
the live show was like the finale for
the Year this will be the last
show and then we'll go on a pretty short
Hiatus it's two weeks it's gonna be
right yeah it'll be two weeks fortnight
it'll be actually a little bit less than
that for us because there's stuff behind
the scenes that we have to do but um the
show will be dark for a two-week period
yeah and you know uh I hate not to be
here for you guys but at the end of the
day we all are real people and uh we do
need to live our real lives to an extent
I mean we hear we here we are here on
this Earth to do things uh outside of
this studio or
Warehouse if you're
stopping down
so that's it uh so yeah but details to
come again probably next week it's we're
getting very close to solidifying
everything so yeah Miriam says two weeks
is a long time I agree it feels like a
long [__] time but you know in most
places it's normal to get a month off
uh and and I believe in that I mean if
you think about it you're working 12
months a year what you get one twelfth
of it to yourself it's still not a lot
you know but uh that's the nature of our
job and uh we do want to be here for you
guys as much as possible but at the end
of the day we do need uh to balance
things especially for longevity right I
mean none of nobody wants to see us get
burned out
so one of the thing is that I think you
know that does happen to us around the
fall as you know you're nine months into
doing shows every day every week and uh
it's hard not to get a little burnt out
but every time we take a break I'm
always hungry to come back
I watch so many compilation vids from
the podcast we get charged up definitely
sorry to interrupt we got to go to a
break uh so so yeah maybe we'll do
something in June
we asked to denounce the time
um all right let's talk about this
YouTuber so a couple in Southern
California is facing multiple felony
charges after causing allegedly causing
car accidents they posted on YouTube and
and insurance fraud scheme that they
record and put on YouTube and this is I
love this the video footage is stunning
it's stunning I literally gasped when I
saw it so here's what they look like
here's homie
uh
uh Temple kind of if he'd never got into
politics I don't know
I don't know
it's more like a shoe
oh chewy yeah if Chewie had a scheme
right oh man and uh of course uh the
lovely
uh shoe shoe uh shoes
this all happened uh by the way in San
Bernardino which yeah I gotta say that
is a San Bernardino ass couple right
there
as
that is who I imagine so on their
YouTube channel they have 162 videos
of vehicle collisions attempted
collisions and other road rage incidents
that's crazy they're both 40 years old
now
this is going to blow your [__] mind
uh here is
some footage that was compiled
yeah their channel was taken down so
yeah YouTube nuked the Channel Once the
story broke but I'm surprised dude they
had
162 videos that's crazy watch this
wait
somebody in the chat just said I sent
this channel to Dan and a b in 2021 so
happy it's finally being talked about oh
wow what oh my God I mean I used it on
this I must have missed your message uh
because this definitely blew us away
once we saw it yeah did they have a fan
base
it was apparently a known enough thing
that some of our fans were like yo you
got to check out this channel oh geez so
here they are so I mean here they are
trying to get the bag they just straight
up swerve at this guy and caught I mean
I don't see how they're gonna they're
trying to get hit
they're they're gonna kill someone [__]
is so scary watch this [__]
what the [__] dude sideswiped
there gotta be tweaking or something man
this super they're literally chasing
this person down after sideswiping him
keep you keep your hands off my [__]
car yeah
dude oh my God this person's scared
they're running for the lives
dude
so apparently they're out there trying
to scheme people although it's clear
that they are the cause of all those so
I'm not sure how the scheme was there
they have 17 insurance claims
they have against them or against others
I just says they were linked to 17 but
it's probably a variety maybe sometimes
there are false sometimes they're not
the investigators say the channel
featured 23 collisions that were linked
to 17 insurance claims filed by him
so yeah he's trying to get a payouts
the insurance company I think after
maybe 16 is going to start to raise
their eyes what he said it was a good
scheme
clearly it wasn't it's a scheme
not a good one
the channel also features 42 videos of
Road Rage which investor investigators
say appear to be intentional Acts
uh too bad we don't have more footage I
have one more right here
yeah I want to see more of this why you
uploading it why are you uploading the
evidence of your insurance fraud they're
listen they're smart people they're
trying to make money on YouTube and uh
they're hustling you have to mute it
though Jeremy perils is one of the
people who was involved in an accident
on the channel he claims that on April
2022 he was driving normally when the
car ahead driven by Christopher Phelps
started slowing down and came to a stop
for no reason
he took evasive action and steered into
the opposite lane at which time he
claims Phelps drove into him it's like
what is happening Bizarro world he knows
what he's doing and he knows how to not
be at fault
okay if you say so here's one here's a
road rage one
so he's really playing music right
foreign
oh my God
brakes checks hard yeah I mean if you
get rear-ended they usually just default
to whoever hit you so exactly I mean
that one at least makes sense like how
you would make that claim the other ones
were him just like sideswipe like Fast
and Furious style I don't know how
that's gonna work out this one looks
like a pretty good scheme like I think
he could get paid off that oh my neck
right exactly ah
all right
I mean the guy was kind of tailgating
him to be fair
well that's why they say not to tailgate
right
not necessarily because of somebody
trying to commit insurance fraud but if
somebody Slams on the break you got to
leave room yeah well you got you have
you need to be defensive driver that's
right you know I mean
okay dude you're about to
about to pay out brother
the guy's tailgating you and now he's
he's paying for it so that's a dog who's
wrong with the neck brace for a couple
months you're gonna get paid these
aren't all that channel it's just that
clip this isn't a compilation that yeah
it just sleep to these kinds of videos
do you really I've actually seen in the
chat a lot of people saying they love
these ASMR crash videos
no there's close calls and stuff like
that and sometimes they listen to music
in the car and it's nice it's nice well
there's another detail about this couple
is that their child was actually found
in the car in some of the videos oh I
couldn't find this well what are they
supposed to do leave them at home by
himself Jesus Christ it's so stupid
you got I mean the kids are in the back
so the tailgating uh the they're kind of
more at Rich it's a little bit uh
a little bit uh more dark but there's a
kid in there they might even be like yo
you [__] my kid up
he's the kid oh man yeah why not I mean
why wouldn't they
um Christopher and Kimberly both are
facing felony charges of child
endangerment and insurance fraud
Christopher is also being charged with
assault with a deadly weapon both have
pled not guilty good luck with that
it's all on tape brother you uploaded it
off to YouTube uh your honor not guilty
those are all authentic and real
collisions
he's being held on half a million
dollars bail
while her bail was reduced to a generous
170 000.
yeah I mean listen the Kid ah that sucks
that there's a kid involved that always
[__] sucks
I tell you man
I kind of had to stop watching True
Crime because
hold on I'm reading the text
this must have been
extremely recent development it is it
happened just the other day I had
watched like all the True Crime on like
TV the documentaries the Dateline the
2020 I've seen it all prime so I went to
YouTube and watched these ones
and I I really like a lot of them
because my favorite part of these True
Crime is just like the police
interrogation like the videos of
actually stuff happening
but they're they're they don't edit as
much like usually when you watch
dateliner 2020 or documentary there's a
story involves
but the one I saw was just plain
disturbing I watch Like specific
YouTubers who tell you the case so like
they'll present all of the information
to you and then put the Clips in and it
just feels like someone is telling you
a story well there's the JCS one right
there any other really good one I mean
there's uh yeah I like Kendall Ray I
really love Kendall Ray because I need
someone to curate this because
okay Kindle Ray so good I need someone
to curate us she's she's great she's a
fan of the show Kendall okay cool I'm
gonna watch her videos then because I
also recommend Stephanie Harlow let me
look her I just want to
Stephanie
Harlow
Prime
because what I saw okay great this these
are my these are my my gals love it so
I'm gonna watch these
but what I saw was um
usually when it involves kids I I can't
do it it's just it [__] me up like
genuinely like there's this one story
that's like a dateline 2020 classic that
with this guy who
basically murdered his two children in
Cold Blood just so he could like move
because he just don't have kids anymore
he wanted to go be in a new relationship
it's a famous One Chris Watts
he did he kill his wife as well yeah
that's Chris Watts and the part that
[__] me up the most is that his
daughters were begging for their life
from their own [__] dad really saying
why why daddy oh
it's pretty horrific and so I saw one
that was like that this dude
he is like a middle child he's about
like I don't know 17 years old about
you guys didn't want to hear about this
it's [__] up yeah little sister and uh
the description of it was just haunting
and frankly it [__] me up wow like he
he slit her
he slit her throat while she was on her
back said I didn't want to hear about it
facing up at her and she was talking to
him while he was doing it saying like
why are you killing me
and they're like they're like best
friends she trusted him [__] L
brother it uh it actually is [__]
deeply Disturbed me and I'm on a deep
deep True Crime break
it's probably good yeah that's why I
don't I don't like True Crime stuff
personally so no some of it's amazing
because the stories are like [__]
crazy yeah I'll read fiction I like the
uh it's better
this is better
uh but God some of them are just like
that one's not curated it was just like
there was no redeeming value there was
no interesting story it was just strange
morbid horrid just horrible man and his
his younger sister is about Theodore's
age
she was like four and it just [__]
Disturbed me so deeply
so yeah well cool
very cool
I'm on a deep deep break of it
uh no this one's supposed to be funny
I'm just kind of talking what's on my
mind
uh you know what I mean
yeah it's still with me to be honest
seems like it wow you seem haunted I'm
changed man
yeah
it's just
some things I don't need to know
you know
and then there was this other one no I'm
just kidding
okay well that's about it can we get
some chestnuts please Zack
[Music]
and then when the police were
interviewing him no
[Music]
yeah yeah I did
so but I'm gonna I will give a chance to
um
to the girls you recommended right well
also feel free to take your break it
sounds like you need to clear it the
break might be a good dog it's just
they'll still be there when you're ready
it's the one with kids I think I just
need to bail when it involves kids
[Music]
I'm sorry Zach did you intentionally
play that because he says there are
people dying
Maybe
they got me oh [__]
oh here
we are almost
[Music]
make it brighter day
yeah all right well tomorrow's leftovers
uh-huh
will be a lot of fun as always got some
good stuff and I'm very very very
excited about Friday's show so I hope
you guys will join us then uh thank you
again to our members
huge difference
and thanks everyone for being here you
know family family mm-hmm
that's right all right
that is right people
with peace and love and sorry about
those disturbing images just move on
don't look for it just wipe it for me
remember forget it forget
that I said anything
I won't I can't
like I literally can't forget it
is it possible to get PTSD from watching
a true crime video
if anyone could it would be you I mean
it's so [__] disturbing
just like a precious four-year-old she's
so innocent all right bye everybody
we'll see you tomorrow morning I got 10
o'clock Pacific on leftovers
[Music]
oh